joshua
my pleasure to be here thank you what's
up my brother thank you so much for
coming on the program
thank you man so popped i always believe
in gratitude because
they say all of success which is merely
the progressive realization
of a worthy idea or goal can be summed
up with one word
and that's attitude because everything
we do has an equal and opposite
reaction right and so you know people
just react to the way we act
and so if you take the word attitude and
put you know a gr in front of it you get
gratitude and i always say you have to
be
grateful in order to become great yep
yeah we have to become grateful to
become great and
also you can't be grateful and angry at
the same time
and we're grateful to matt mckibben
oh my god bringing us together amazing
love you so much brother we love you
matt if you're listening to this we love
you so much
this has been one of my favorite los
angeles intros so far and i'm just
been so pumped for this conversation
we're gonna unpack
piercing the veil of reality we're gonna
unpack
so many great aspects to patterns in
nature
cracking search engine optimization the
synthesis of science and spirituality
the nature of consciousness god reality
ridiculously pumped you're one of my
favorite tennis players
oh yeah well because we both know we can
hit the ball you know that's right
we know we're not gonna hit it towards a
dead end that's right that's right
okay joshua erp comes from the
lineage of wyatt earp which is very
interesting
let's unpack the journey though as much
detail as you'd like to share with us
yeah who were you growing up what's up
with your lineage how did you pick
up the interests that you care about
yeah
i mean even though the wider you know
family bloodline i guess you know
some consider hollywood royalty or
whatever i actually grew up with
you know no money i grew up with you
know didn't know anybody in the middle
of illinois which is where whiter is
from
and there was nothing around me except
churches and cornfields and that's
it so you know they always say if
opportunity doesn't
knock you have to build the door so i
decided you know i was just going to
keep building doors until finally it
started knocking you know
so but no it's you know so that's where
i came from
i was always interested in the human
mind you know i was always interested in
and uh you know entheogenic
uh you know properties i was always
interested in and um
mentalism and magic and hypnosis and and
really just supernatural paranormal
things
um you know rooted in science you know
not necessarily rooted in
um you know any more of the less
intangible stuff even though as you know
as well
it's everything is pretty much
metaphysical because you know
anyone who ever that's why napoleon hill
wrote the book think and
up which was really just a long-form
sales letter for his much larger work
you know the laws of success
um and even that he ripped off of uh
wallace d
wattles you know science of getting rich
or borrowed rather not ripped off you
know because picasso
said good artist copy great artist steal
right i mean hey if you have
universal principles that work why not
just regurgitate them and
sell millions of copies which by the way
it's the second best-selling book
you know next to the bible my friend don
green's the ceo of the napoleon hill
foundation
and um the thing is is um
you know it's the second bestselling
book next to the bible and it's created
more millionaires than any other book in
history
and um there's a whole chapter dedicated
to
one of my favorites is the mystery of
sex transmutation which we can get into
but also
uh the whole chapter dedicated to
enthusiasm which believe it or not the
two
actually tie hand in hand and that like
i said
yeah anthogenic properties is enthused
right which is esoteric or inner
rather than exoteric outer which is
excitement you know
yeah yeah unleashing the divine within
amen to that exactly yeah so
what about this finding yourself
growing up in illinois and setting
yourself up with these
opportunities that awakened you more and
more to the biggest questions about
reality and then the move to los angeles
how did that happen
yeah so instead of going out and
networking and finding the right people
you have to first become the right
person
you know that was a big breakthrough for
me so everything and everyone that i've
attracted into my life
is the direct result of the person that
i became
you know in the process and so rather
than going out there looking for it
right you must
search in here and um what were some of
those things though that
led you to that in investigation
of awareness and the upgrading of your
own
state of consciousness to higher
vibration how did that
those triggers happen was it someone in
the lineage was it
yeah there's really not much you know in
the lineage necessary i mean besides i
guess
or was it think and grow rich was it
like things like that think and grow
rich really had a profound effect
on me because it's basically saying you
know write your goals in
stone right but write the methods in
sand meaning that you have to be
stubborn about your goals but be
flexible with your methods and if you
don't end up hitting your goal
you don't change the goal you simply
change the methodology
you know in order to get you there in
fact and that ties in also with counter
factual simulation
which is uh you know basically reverse
engineering you know the end result like
dr stephen covey the author of you know
the seven habits of highly effective
people which he also
borrowed that those ideas from another
source hey we all do though yeah nothing
against those guys or anything
in fact it's great for them to bring
this stuff to light right which light is
consciousness and consciousness is
information
um but anyway so um he always says begin
with the end in mind
right and so the whole thing is in stone
but having the trajectory be more like
sand
flexible yeah and so the thing is is um
what's a good analogy here so basically
you know it's all about counter factual
simulation so let me explain kind of
more about that
so it's beginning with the end in mind
essentially but there's more to it so
counter factual simulation is the basis
in which all science fiction is written
right which science was founded by a man
by the name of rene de car upon an
angelic vision so even
you know science itself is practical as
it is has its roots in
you know the occult or esotericism or
mysticism right
and so science fiction the root of all
of it right is
is uh counterfactual simulation so it's
asking yourself the question
what would it look like if blank
happened
okay so in science fiction it might look
like something like this what would it
look like
if something crazy happened and then
their
their mind or their hand will just start
kind of automatic writing it'll just
automatically start filling in the gaps
right so when it comes to setting goals
and success or relationships or health
or anything like that
we have to begin with the end in mind
okay and um
but before that though one thing i also
want to say is that
you know i can even show you an
experiment so and it would look it would
look something
like like this i would i would assume we
would have like in chapter 2 and c
theory and high level perception you
have that sort of birth point and then
you have this big north star
and that that's what you write in stone
as you're describing in these
science fiction sort of writings and
then you're very
loose in terms of the trajectory space
of the ways in sand for you to actually
attain said yeah the purpose of life is
to discover your purpose
and so so the whole thing is is if i
were to ask you let's do an example
right now an analogy right so if i were
to ask you
what would it look like if you were
standing on the moon
and you looked around you what would
that look like
beautiful do you see how your brain
began immediately configuring a mental
image of what it would look like i love
it well that right there is called
counter factual simulation yeah so when
it comes to like i said
why it has to be counter factual because
in computer science we also call this a
monte carlo tree search or
a model based reinforcement learning i'm
why does it have to be counter
factual because it's assimilated
is that why it could be well basically
what i was getting at with that point is
that um
i'm just wondering in terms of the
branding yeah but just because it's like
jordan peterson also calls it future
authoring i like jordan peterson a lot
yeah yeah um
once again he's using language which is
a phenomenon to describe other
phenomenon right so you can only go so
far
in that direction but one thing i was
going to say just to finish the thought
is the same way your brain began
immediately configuring
regardless of the terminology whether
it's counterfactual or not
the the same way that your brain began
mentally configuring that image
is what they what is known as counter
factual stimulation and so the whole
thing is
is uh when it comes to success right you
just set the goal
and then your brain will begin just like
you did with the moon exercise
which will get into the moon and nasa
and all this other stuff with you know
translucent objects and
and all that but the whole thing is is
your brain will automatically fill in
the gaps
to get you there and reverse engineer
the steps that it takes to get to that
goal you know regardless of what the
terminology is called
yeah i would definitely completely
concur that that in
essence that you seem to have identified
at a very young
age is super rich and valuable and then
now the way that you're sharing it with
other people
super rich and valuable yeah i would say
that
from what i understand the idea that we
were
that we've been sharing as
counterfactual simulation or this idea
of a north star
or this idea of monte carlo research or
model based reinforcement learning
i would say that future authoring i
agree with you
in principle that it's that principle
that is
paramount to do but i would also
argue that the mimetic label
is extremely important in the sense of
the
more precise concise
and storytelling that it becomes explain
like i'm five
which is why north star is pretty
[ __ ] good
and it's better than monte carlo tree
surge counterfactual simulation
mbrl future authoring future authoring
is pretty simple but
north star seems to be most
simple and
that is
what is needed for children to
at younger ages than even we awaken to
these phenomena
grasp it and then have that sort of
divine realization
what the [ __ ] is my north star because i
want to actualize gifts into the world
and then that's where we i love that
okay so then
you had these profound moments when you
were growing
up yeah those were some of the big
triggers of even moving to l.a
yeah so i'll just go over the whole
story you know um
and so basically at the age of eight
years old
okay growing up in illinois i started
playing guitar you know
and that's whenever i discovered the
pythagorean golden ratio of two to one
and
the twelfth fret on the guitar repeats
back at one at 13
as well and so you know i've always had
this very mathematical symphonic
orchestral type of
brain you know that just is fascinated
by all this stuff you know
um but so eight years old is when i
started
and actually being ambidextrous which
i'm not ambidextrous but
you know guitar you know definitely
helps with your dexterity right
but being ambidextrous is actually what
unlocks you know the two hemisphere of
the brains kind of like monoatomic white
gold and ormus which
you know balances the two hemispheres of
the brain as well um but anyway so you
can practice just brush your teeth with
your left hand sometimes
yeah try to cook cut cut some vegetables
with your left hand yeah my friend
actually would teach
how to uh become ambidextrous by taking
two pens at the same time
and drawing as small of the circle as
you possibly can and then slowly making
them bigger over time and
training your brain he basically trains
genius which by the way benjamin
franklin said that you know like i said
earlier is that
genius is simply a greater aptitude for
patience i believe any human can be
trained to do anything
um you know if you you'll basically what
i'm trying to say is you'll find a way
or you you're either going to find an
excuse yeah
yeah okay so you were in eight years old
picking up guitar
music guitar magic okay so magic not
magic with a k which is ceremonial and
ritualistic in nature
which is all about um affecting the
outcomes at eve of events
through um you know at a distance right
which is is real
by the way in fact back in the day magic
and in the hermetic
occultic divinatory sciences and modern
day
science which we'll talk about later i'm
sure were the two main branches and over
time
you know magic the real magic not with
the c not illusions the ceremonial
ritualistic
magic based off of intent um you know
was way too powerful for a bunch of
uh low-life um you know peasants which
is what the elite or predatory class
look at us has
um it was way too powerful to be in our
hands and so they
they slowly and mostly slowly not so
slowly did away with that
and then now they only teach us capital
s science which is
basically the new religion it's all
based on you know scientists can be
bought just as easily as politicians you
know and so
anytime we have mainstream um you know
people
of scientific nature you know trying to
um
you know say and depict this false view
of reality upon the lower class you know
i just don't buy it
you know it's just like the big bang
theory you know it's like there was
nothing
and then nothing exploded and then it
created something i just don't
buy it you know if you like there i just
don't buy it man you know and
uh the thing is is um you know it's like
it's
you just gotta make sure that you're
being force-fed this information
from uh the elite from a very early age
for a reason and it's not for your own
benefit
you know so anyway back to the story
because i know i'm kind of going all
over the place eight years old started
learning mentalism
which is an ancient occult science the
word occult don't let that freak you out
it's nothing like the word cult occult
stems from the latin word akhotare which
means secret or hidden
so you know when someone says they have
vast knowledge of the occult that means
they have
vast forbidden or secret or hidden
knowledge right
which knowledge comes from the greek
word gnosis and where you get hypnosis
as well and gnosticism which is kind of
like you know greek mysticism
similar to how the kabbalah is jewish
magic or jewish mysticism correct
which you know comprises of various
cephados or sapphires the lowest being
yasad
in hebrew which means the foundation
which all stems back from the ancient
babylonian mystery traditions
and was carried through you know the
freemasonic and rosicrucian
and jesuitism and the illuminated series
of bavarian societies
and other coming sonic societies that
have been the connective tissue from the
ancient mysteries to that
of uh today and so anyway long story
short
now here's tom with the weather no i'm
just kidding but um but anyway so
what i'm saying is yes so from eight
years old i started learning all this
stuff magic mentalism hypnosis
um you know i started experimenting with
anthogenic substances
um you know like uh for phosphoryl oxy
in in dimethyltryptamine which is the
psychedelic psilocybin mushroom which is
um
you know uh mushrooms were the first
organisms to come to land
billions of years before plants and
we're more related to the fungi
kingdom than any other kingdom more than
the animal kingdom the insect kingdom
you know etc etc so anyway so that's
kind of how i started now
so i've always been involved in
entertainment since i was young because
that's just
you know my dna i guess that's what i
wanted to do that's
who i wanted to become i wanted to you
know just express myself through music
kind of like pythagoras did which music
has a very
um you know key role in in earlier
secret societies as well
because it all ties in with like nikola
tesla said frequency number and
vibration and resonance that's what it
is
so that's how i got my start now i was
always very curious as i'm sure you can
imagine
i always had this incredibly vast thirst
for knowledge i'm i have a student
mentality as much as it seems like i'm
teaching they say whenever you learn
you shall teach and whenever you receive
you shall
give and so that's kind of the whole you
know approach that i've taken
um but anyway so so
my the story of my life basically is so
that's what happened when i was eight
years old
i grew up and you know became
progressively better at the things i
decided to focus on with
unreal uh unrelinquished uh you know
self-discipline and things like that
right
by the way i think you know especially
whenever you dissect you know high
levels of achievement
i think that self-discipline the
neuropsychology of self-discipline
is the closest thing you could have to a
wish-granting fairy godmother yeah
i mean it's like having a genie in a
magic lamp that can grant your every
single wish as long as you know how to
use it correctly or rub it correctly you
know
and so anyway so you know i didn't have
any mentors growing up i didn't have any
teachers i didn't i was all self-taught
you know it's like
i grew up with the internet and i would
research things about when i was very
very young about
cancer in in disease and you know the
human or true human origin and g edward
griffin you know his book world without
cancer really changed my mind on that
completely
and then i got into the creature from
jekyll island about the second look at
the history of the federal reserve and
learned about that very early on and all
this other stuff right
um but there once again i started with
no money i started with
no connections i i basically created
everything i built from scratch and a
lot of people have done that right a lot
of people have done that
um but the whole thing though is is um
you know basically with all that being
said there was no opportunity around me
you know because it was just corn fields
and churches and that's all i had so
um what i decided to do is um i decided
to go into business
right search engine optimization my
first business was actually a stage
hypnosis
business i'm one of the world's fastest
hypnotists by record
for instant inductions and you know
implanting suggestion through the
subconscious mind by
bypassing the critical faculty through
triggering the amygdala and shocking the
central nervous system
which we'll talk about that in a little
bit if you want but i also broke the
world's record for
bpm on guitar so that i broke i'm one of
the fastest guitar players if not the
fastest in the world
according to the fact that i broke 2 000
beats per minute
through sweet picking uh arpeggios you
know is what it's called on guitar so
anyway there's that
um but anyway so
what did i do is i went to the internet
you know and i started learning i
started teaching myself there's so many
people that you know have trouble making
money and the first question i ask well
how much time
do you spend how many hours a day do you
spend learning
how to make money and they always seem
surprised and they always say well you
know
zero and i say well
if you spend zero hours a day learning
how to make money
and you look in your bank account
there's no money there then like
it's the cognitive dissonance is
astronomically exponential you know
it's very anomalous in nature so it's a
phenomenic
phenomenon or see how i did that i
switched the words it's not a
anomaly phenomenon it's i switched it
backwards but uh
anyway so long story short is um that's
kind of what happened and so i started
getting really good at it
yeah let's unpack you guys so much so
much i love it
as as you can tell joshua's
lattice work of concepts is
across many different fields
and that's why we relate so deeply
because it's very
synthesis driven and it's also
it's also what gives so many unique
insights
across the disciplines is when you've
been able to do that
so i really like all that about you a
lot
and there's tons of things in there that
you mentioned that that will probably
end up like you said revisiting as we go
into later parts of the conversation but
most specifically i think what's
relevant into what we're about to dive
into is
the idea that
you found out over time
that similar to me with sioux falls
south dakota and you being in illinois
many people as they gravitate out to
metropolis
is for something that is potentially
higher up on the fitness landscape in
terms of
people in terms of ideas in terms of
execution capacity things like that
that you created your own opportunities
and that in the in the sense it was
driven by this idea of the star and that
this idea of the star for you
is that this very simple fundamental
question to ask
which is something along the lines of
how many hours a day am i spending on
learning how to make money
yeah but it's it's not just money it's
totally you know
totally it's how many hours a day that's
am i dedicated to my north star
specifically and money's one of the
tools we use to help
us accelerate that very low vibration
it's very
you know and it has to be in mind
ethical and moral and spiritual along
the journey
and so specifically i love i love that
question and then also i love the
the perspective of as
you figure out over time
what the most because from this very
synthetic
perspective you're identifying patterns
you're basically
able to explore more
patterns across the different
disciplines and then that enables you to
come to these realizations that
given a specific person's north star
there's specific patterns that enable
them to achieve it most efficaciously
yeah and it's you know like charlie
munger said there's some people that
know
a little bit about a little there's some
people that know a little bit about a
lot and there's some people that know a
lot about a lot you know and i always
considered myself more on the polymath
side
me too but i'm the complete opposite of
scattered you know i i
really when i go to master something i i
spend all my time effort and energy i
put my ten thousand hours in
and i'm very very focused because you
know
laser-like focus is what separates an
average man from a warrior
and um you know what we focus on expands
and um
you know bruce lee said that i don't
fear a man who practices a thousand
kicks a day
i fear many practices one kick a
thousand times a day well that's what i
did and then after i mastered that kick
i went on to the next one after that to
the next one
um it got to the point like you know
like being the world's fastest hypnotist
and
fastest guitar player and this and that
and i can go down the list or whatever
but
it just it just i just do it until the
point where i'm not intellectually
stimulated anymore i've completely
mastered it
i know all the scales on guitars all the
notes you can possibly play i know all
the
you know like it's it just gets to the
point where you get bored
and then you move on okay then i
mastered martial arts and then i went on
to
master um you know magic and then after
that mentalism which you know will show
you guys some cool stuff maybe um after
this
um but then also you know hypnosis and
then
business and then i learned business and
i learned internet marketing and i
completely mastered internet marketing
in and of itself all the way down from
the email marketing sequences to
retargeting paid ads list building
like everything you can imagine like
neuro-linguistic programming
in terms of direct response copywriting
elements such as presuppositions
embedded commands future pacing and
other hypnotic language patterns and
then i got to the point where i
mastered internet marketing right
because everything's all about
fundamentals elements and principles
right
and so once i mastered that then i moved
on to search engine optimization because
that's it's a recursive mathematical
algorithm which just means that it's
like the fibonacci sequence you know eli
five
explained like i'm five right it's just
completely recursive in nature meaning
it keeps on going
and so the fact that seo is an algorithm
that's constantly being updated and
changed
it was like a puzzle to me so so seo was
the only
of the you know internet marketing
disciplines which is the most important
thing in today's
economic digital you know innovative
environment
uh to learn that seo is why what i chose
because that's the only thing that could
keep me intellectually stimulating
you know and that's specifically because
the algorithm for
search engine optimization is constantly
being
updated over time based on
the the addition
of the millions
of web pages and companies that enter
the space
for example it wasn't as
common for people to have even
tick-tock profiles like a year or two
ago yeah and so that in itself
was not so much yeah
part of the algorithm that we would need
to
update so the seo seo in a sense keeps
your ability let's see if i can hit this
in general
seo keeps the
individual artists as they're achieving
their north star
it keeps their ability to
become the most efficacious around
especially the distillation of mimetics
that inspire people to pay attention
to what they're doing on their north
star journey as something yeah
and sometimes you know one of my you
know advisors is a
billionaire and he um you know he
manages a lot of older hollywood stars
money and stuff you know and he always
says you know
do what makes the most money the fastest
and then do what you love
and i would imagine the reason he said
that is because if you just
only do what you love all the time you
might be doing what you love on the
street
you know um so it's like so it's that
fine balance between
you know step one is survive step two is
thrive right
and so and use the money to fund your
passion you know so even though
you may not let's say you want to become
the world's greatest singer right even
though you may have to do
seo or work some other side job or
whatever it is to get to that point
at least you still have that north star
intact and even though it seems like
you're going in this direction
you know you're doing what makes the
most money the fastest so then you can
do what you love and you're sacrificing
a few years of your life doing the
things no one else would do or want to
do
to live the rest of your life in a way
that no one else can
yep another one of the perennial
wisdoms of those that are
passing along the most efficacious
trajectory enhancing techniques
to achieve north stars and
in this case the more that you become
i love this one the more that you become
enriched around your understanding of
the way that
seo works the more you're able to
achieve that north star most
efficaciously in many ways i mean a lot
of people want to just be a good parent
there's very there's a big color wheel
of options of what people want to
achieve in
the world and so a lot of the times it's
not something that is
hyper up the bell curve and wanting to
impact a billion people
which is what we're talking about right
now which is becoming the absolute best
memetic distiller and communicator so
that people pay attention
to what updates you're trying to cast
on the planet but and even then that's
the same thing's
true for what you were just saying a
moment ago which is that a lot of people
have to be patient like you were saying
earlier about
wanting to do something that may be
ethical money attainment
and then fueling that into the north
star fire
but that's again that's usually for
something that if someone says that well
maybe my north star for maybe the color
orange on the color wheel is maybe
something along the lines of well
i'm cool with i'm cool with maybe just
running a business in my local city and
that's pretty much it yeah and being a
good parent
and that's a great point and so that's
why i said in the beginning
success by definition right is the
progressive
keyword progressive right realization
right realization right of a worthy
idea or goal so what that means is the
woman that's working at the gas station
is just as successful as the man that
went to school to become a doctor given
that that's what he or she
wanted to do and so that's a really you
know illustrious point that i think is
crucial it's crucial so the north star
as long as it's a worthy idea or goal
whatever color it is on the color wheel
because it's it's all about the the
journey not the destination
in fact the future is an illusion
whenever we arrive at the future we're
going to discover it's just another
present moment
yeah there's this beautiful balance
between
the absolute highest
in the moment and at the same time
negotiating with that future star
that we're striving towards and um the
universe is malleable you know because
the universe is simply the u
y o u inverse right inverse that equal
opposite reaction so as long as we
progressively go towards our goals it's
like water it's malleable it's going to
eventually get out of your way
you know it's like backing the universe
into a corner as long as you just keep
going in that direction
which direction is more important than
speed right because many are going
nowhere fast
if you keep going in that direction and
you back the universe in the corner
there's there's no other
option but to become a success you know
um
thomas edison said i was bound to
succeed because i simply ran out of ways
that would not work
you know we have like guys like henry
ford that say you know in order to
succeed we must
double our rate of failure and so but we
also have to learn how to survive the
fail as well
and there is no failure until we admit
defeat and so that's why we have to be
flexible with our methods but stubborn
with our goals yes
love that now
i want to maybe take this from as high
macro level of a perspective as possible
so we don't get
lost yeah and then we'll finish my story
in the wheat visitors
this is already this is the one of the
cool parts of the story we got through
the earlier we're kind of in
some of the meat right now yeah and
either any whether my story or not
doesn't matter what matters is the
principles and elements were just
in those foundations like you said
principles elements foundations those
are crucial
well they are they are you you there's a
lot of crucial points along the way that
that people take from that from that
story
all right because we didn't get to vote
when i got in the movie industry and all
those other stuff
yeah we'll get into that later but which
yeah the acting music
there's there's a lot here yeah exactly
well also for round two and beyond
because there's so many more nuances to
unpack and
we'll we'll yeah especially on let's
let's
let's take this from a high level
perspective so
as we attempt to communicate to people
that there is some sort of a
a pattern of how people can most
effectively so let's talk about the
higher performers now so we're not
talking about the
color orange of having one business
which is just another
synonym for the people with actual
self-discipline right
or just a specific color on the wheel
let's say yeah because
purple on the wheel if it is these two
three standard deviations up genius
that's trying to
augment the codes for everybody
excellent but
the person that is the color orange
that's just being a good parent
having a business in a more rural town
great as well beautiful expression of
consciousness as well that's what they
want
if that's what they want to do which
sometimes people aren't exposed to
the ideas and stories and goals and
others that
re that help them realize that maybe i
do want something a little bit more
which is also fair to say
all right so for the purple let's say in
this scenario
so we have
what is people that are trying to
understand okay mr joshua
you are
in many ways very
strategically trained
in seo to the extent at which
you can potentially help me as a high
performer
achieve my north star with greater
efficacy so my question would be
something like this on the most like
macro level
way for this color purple person that's
trying
through whatever medium it is that today
they maybe have their websites they have
their social media accounts
they have their business whether it be a
physical brick-and-mortar business or
something that's
e-commerce related or something that's
strictly media related and advertisement
generating for revenue brand deals all
this different type of stuff
yeah we have your just the generic style
of business and we have the generic
style of websites and social accounts
and all that stuff
what is that top recommendation
or two for this entrepreneur that's
hustling in the seo space
what is the what exactly what's the top
recommendation for this entrepreneur
that's hustling
yeah for them to do in the seo space to
rocket them up
gotcha the first thing i would say is uh
join the amish community
no i'm just kidding that's the complete
opposite no i was just thinking because
when you started talking about social
media and seo i was like damn we are in
the 21st century you know approaching
the next
right um but no
what we do is we reverse engineer
google's patents so we take all the
guesswork out of it we don't believe in
wasting time uh we reverse engineer the
patents a lot of people don't know you
can do that you go to google.com
patents it'll 301 redirect you to the
you know patents.google.com subdomain
and it looks like just a normal search
engine like google may we
maybe yeah exactly it's the patent
search engine i'll show you my favorite
patent okay you said
it's google.com yeah patents and then
what it's going to do is
301 redirect you to patents.google.com
which it looks like just another search
engine but it's actually not okay hold
on a second so
all right so we typed in uh
google.com forward slash patents and we
just got redirected to
it should be patent.google.gov or
something like that but we but it just
took us to for
click on this uh no the browser or yeah
the url oh the url okay click on that
and then hit
command like copy it okay and then paste
it again
okay and what popped up okay so they're
always changing things around it doesn't
matter okay
so here we are though so the whole point
is you're in the patent search engine
they always
do a hard code redirect okay okay so now
type in ranking documents
okay ranking documents okay
okay and then you pull up the first one
actually let's see
yeah okay so the first one so what
you're looking at if you notice real
quick before you click
okay is what we're looking at is not a
typical
google search engine this is the the
patent search engine okay
and most changes that google updates
which by the way
just so you guys understand why we're
even talking about this 97
okay not i mean this is a astronomical
number
97 of all online experiences
in general okay experiences online 97
begins with a search engine yep and
don't get me wrong social media is very
cute okay
you can make money off it it's very cute
but that's only three percent of the pie
you know why would you spend most your
efforts and energy and
uh also most of your money you know on
paid ads or whatever it ends up being
on only three percent i mean it's seo
which is google right essentially i can
do any search engine but
it essentially is the 800 pound gorilla
in the room and it's so big that it's
no one can see it because it's so big
and it's right in front of them and no
one's talking about it you know so it's
like
and it's a really crazy thing but anyway
so 97
of all internet related experiences
so dealing with the circuit begin with
the search so basically the
substrate monopoly right now
is in google's hands and so people as
they go
into the internet
into the online space there's
the way that they do so is via google
ninety-seven percent of all online
experience yeah just search engines
it could be oh okay okay oh oh oh oh so
97
of search engines in general yeah yeah
but if you link on google you pretty
much rank on all of them by default
by default yeah so so that's a good
thing got it oh because there's
we have baidu yeah we have yandex
we have a duckduckgo we have all these
others yeah okay
um but the thing is though is that um
they every time they update their
algorithm they have to publicly declare
it in
in a patent um and so every time through
the uspto they publish
yeah they and they actually take all
their um patents of their search engine
from yahoo and they steal them
essentially
and yahoo and google and uh
whatsapp and dropbox and um all these
other companies okay
are financed by this company called
sequoia capital yep which we're working
with some of the guys there we were
friends with
don valentine before he passed away and
all that which was the head of
uh silicon valley or no he was the head
of sequoia capital
and his nickname was the grandfather of
all silicon valley investing and the
reason why
is because his company sequoia capital
uh they own 33
of nasdaq you know there's that number
33. we'll talk about that later
um but also um you know he always said
in
you know and they they funded apple too
by the way which i've you know spoke on
stage with steve wozniak the videos are
on my instagram
you know i've advised some of the
biggest people in the world and internet
marketers in the world ty lopez
uh frank kern the guy that made the
first million dollars online like
like i'm the guy that teaches all these
all these guys in terms of like
you know algorithms and search engine
optimization um
and all that stuff right i've opened up
for edward snowden i mean there's a lot
of stuff right and those are just a few
as you can see probably by my thing
but um but anyway long story short is
this man
is uh let's go to the ranking documents
yeah so the ranking documents go ahead
and click on the first patent
okay okay so we reverse engineer
google's patents they tell you exactly
what to do it's just most people
don't have you know 16 hours a day for
years on
end to just sit there and distinguish
patents right
but you'll see it says a system
determines a first rank associated with
a document
and then determines the second rank
associated with the document where the
second rank is different from the first
round
sure the system also changes during a
transition
period that occurs during a transition
from the first rank to the second rank
a transition rank associated with the
document based on a rank transition
function that varies the transition rank
over time or any change in ranking
factors
sorry without any change in ranking
factors associated with the document and
you'll see the diagrams as well
so when it comes to your link building
they're really telling you you know what
you should be focused on what you should
not be
in fact some of our diagrams which will
pull up later oh later or we can do it
now if you want we actually
you know leverage and utilize a lot of
their um you know patents to create our
documents this is just one that you're
looking at right here which will
we can come back to it whenever we get
to that point okay but um
but essentially yes you can see they
look similar yeah those diagram
your diagram looks a lot similar yeah we
well what we do is we reverse engineer
google's patents
so we know what works so it takes all
the guesswork out of it right it's
almost like throwing
and then what we do is we scientifically
a b split tests and isolate variables
and controlled experiments
and test different link building
strategies via the patents
to figure out what works and what
doesn't because okay don't code
everything that they put in
okay let's let's try and break this down
so
the it seems as though
this first sentence is describing how
the first rank is different than the
second rank
yes and that then you as you describe
is that then
there's a process of being able to
do a a split
an a b split where
you can determine
which one of those two is going to be
more
fruitful for ranking yourself
higher not not necessarily this the
reason why this patent is relevant is
just because once you start the link
building process which is how you rank
your site
because essentially all the internet is
is a bunch of web documents that
link to other web documents it's called
a citation essentially right
so that's all that's why i don't care
how many times google updates their
algorithm it doesn't matter to me
because i know the principles
of the internet like sir tim berners-lee
that created you know in cern the uh
hypertext transfer protocol
which is now hypertext transfer protocol
secured https and all that
i'm basically just so you know i'm an
http trap lord
that's what i am now um but anyway so
the whole thing though just so you
understand is the reason why this is
relevant is once you start
it's nodes that are linked to other
nodes exactly and so when you begin
visualizing it in that sort of graph
theory
way then you're attempting to
see which nodes have the power law
ranking
yeah popularity and what
relationships or connections there are
to other nodes that have
in links to that node yeah specifically
you can say it like that um essentially
we go to auction and have domain brokers
and we
buy and acquire the most powerful seo
domains
on the internet we circumvent the whole
process by
you know buying domains that already
have great seo
that you know that already spent years
and years and years because once you
forget to renew your hosting or
registration that's right and it goes to
an auction pool where guys like me bid
on it or it gets you know
lost or whatever so i buy these nodes or
these domains that already have great
seo
and then i just upload content to them
and link out to my client so whenever
google sees all these high quality
websites
linking to this website yep then they
give it more of a boost in the search
engine because the way
google's so let's let's just keep
breaking this down along the way so then
there's
a over the last 20 plus years there have
been more
and more domains really high quality
domains that have built up their
seo ranking over time but then what
happened is maybe the brand
you know begins to stop producing its
product or service
number of reasons person dies there's
all different types of reasons the
entrepreneur doesn't
pay the host forget to pay it yeah and
so then it goes to the auction house and
then
yeah registration and then so goes to
the auction and then
there's people like you that are
basically
power law ranking the domains that have
the absolute
highest seo and then you're purchasing
those
and then what you're doing on those
domains that are
already have this like 20 year
potentially history
of high seo is you're then creating
in links to your clients websites
so you could maybe make a blog you can
maybe make a blog on there and then
write content relevant content that
links in links to your clients
and then google's like wow look at this
20-year
uh domain that is that's been around
that is in linking to
these new companies with thousands of
links already pointing to it and i'm
just
i just saved so much time i i'm telling
you bro
i'm like the seo zen master bro i'm
telling you um
but no i'm the http chap lord
trap lord that's funny yeah i've been
doing this a long time 10 years i've
been doing seo yeah
justice yeah yeah so like i take this up
very seriously for sure that's mastery
for sure
yeah it is talking about ten thousand
hours i put in ten years yeah exactly
you have 24 hours a day besides sleep of
course yeah yeah
but anyway so and then we've automated
that process okay so would you say
that's where and automate that process
yes correct yes so would you say that
what you just described
including the software automation that's
basically doing the process of running
scripts to find the expired
domains that have the good history to
purchase they're not necessarily expired
they're but yeah exactly like and would
you say that
this process that we're describing right
now right here
would you say that this is the as i
asked that question earlier
is this the number one thing that people
can be looking at
this is the number this is what ranks
your website so let me explain how
google
i want i want yeah let's say
simulation series or whoever else
insert your business url here your
business url
you would want simulation series to get
someone that already has a domain
that has been around for two decades to
in-link to simulation series is
basically writing a blog and saying that
it's a vote so they're basically voting
that my
side it's a citation they're voting that
they're citing that allen's simulation
series dot com
node that's only three years old
actually is
really highly useful and so they're
citing that and
creating the illusion that your site is
very useful now here's the thing
even if your site wasn't very useful we
still make it appear that way to google
because it's a robot it's not a human it
can't think so it's all based on numbers
and mathematics
but we do want it to be valuable
we don't want junk to show up at the top
i can rank anything
but you can also hybridize the ai
with human to where the humans making
sure that it's something that's actually
valuable
and that's a really good intention as
well in a sense because
i don't want things that are malevolent
showing up just because somebody went
and did the process like
your intent that's my goal that's the
role of the whole show is to do that
what's the idea you need to blockchain
the seo industry because no one has done
it yet and it's an 80 billion
a year industry and it's only growing
and no one's blockchained it out because
no one understands it the way that i
understand it
yeah and so what do you mean by
blockbuster by the way you know how like
because i have friends that have like
the number one marijuana blockchain
company that literally
you know tracks the yes you know the all
the way from cbd
you know so we could do the same thing
with the domains or we could do the same
thing with seo processes
and oracle's intuition in terms of uh
you know and also the block stack and
things like that as well you know
uh interesting so that's not done it
hasn't been done it's not been done
there's no one that's doing it seo is
the wild wild west but there's no one
that's doing
the decentralized uh
blockchain for domains specifically well
even even if they did it for domains
like domains are not seo you know like i
could have all the world's best seo
but you wanna overlay seo on top of the
decentralization idea around domains and
ownership of the nodes
but you also want to include the seo
which was those relationships between
the nodes so when i link from website a
to website b
there's a link going there so whatever
that link says the blue hypertext
portion like click here go
here it might be a keyword whatever
that's called anchor text
right that's the anchor that's going to
it and so
your anchor text portfolio right the
percentage of
the amount and probability you're using
of different keyword oriented anchor
text
and branded in url and partial match
anchor text
plays a role in it you know so so it's
not just about the domains in fact i can
there's a lot of ways to do it without
even using domains but
so would it be smart for the person
insert domain here in this case we'll
use simulation series
it would be smart for us
to do our best to find
to find existing sites
that have a lot of say
and basically write do our best to make
a relationship with them or purchase it
ourselves
every domain is on a unique ip address
and the whois information is blocked
and every domain has its own unique
registration and
hosting account so there's literally no
way for google or anyone to
tell who it is or what we're doing you
know there's no way for them to figure
this out for us that's they'd have to
change their entire algorithm and
they're not going to do that
because 97 of all google advertising
or sorry all google's revenue comes from
advertising and the only reason they do
that is because they have
um by the way that's awesome that you're
so in-depth on the seo usually people
are
shows over there yeah i mean this is
just the start so listen to this
you and uh igor lentermann and harvey
pratt from the semantic
web episode that are making the
three-dimensional
layer where you actually see the
sub-graphs
of the hyper graph as you're looking up
things
yeah you guys you too that i was even
thinking about that before we started
3.0 and yeah we're you guys i'll make
sure that that that's a good thing
that's
really really good yeah yeah you know i
was like putting stuff into freebase you
know before it was
before they took it down and everything
you know i've i got a crazy history with
seo but i mean
i learned from guys that were doing seo
before it was ever called seo it was
back when you paid someone to list your
business number one in the yahoo
business director you know this is the
thing about polymaths
and synthesis especially when well
rooted
in science and spirituality is that you
get these
really nice tennis's games that we can
then
put as multiple rounds out to the world
that then help the entrepreneurs that
have these north star ambitions
begin doing more and more around things
like what you've trained ten years in
doing
but also like we're going to unpack all
these other subjects mentalism conscious
got all these other subjects
it'll be really interesting to hear your
angle given
what you've been sharing even so far so
it's
you know it's really it's that seeing
the true
interconnected and interdependence of
everything
what better way to hit it than on an seo
which is
literally the online space
it's organic and it converts higher than
paid traffic and it's
um you know it's more sustainable and
it's more reliable
and um it's uh has a higher return on
investment over time
and it's unlike paid advertising the
moment you stop you know the ads your
traffic's cut off
seo you're creating an asset or domain
right that's self-sustainably and
self-reliably
consistently generating residual income
through the perpetuation of
uh generating targeted leads that are
qualified in your specific market with a
specific transactional intention
and seo is the only way that you in the
history of marketing and advertising
seo is the only way you can target based
off intention
so let me so that brings me to that next
to it let's do it so we reverse engineer
google's patents then what we do is we
reverse engineer the top competitors we
see who are the other philosophical
intellectual thought leaders that are
into simulation you know shows and
things like that that are
in your market and we figure out who
those people are and we take their
websites
and we use our software to reverse
engineer their website
to show us what keywords that they're
targeting because our competitors have
already spent a lot of money
and a lot of time figuring all this out
so we can piggyback off their success
and we can reverse engineer the top
keywords from their website that's
proven to bring them in traffic and
sales
and target based off of intention which
is a something you cannot do
okay at all okay and paid advertising or
any other form of marketing
so so we have let's see here let's see
if we can get this right
so we have one is that there's the
reverse engineer of the google patents
and then we have then we reverse
engineer
the competitors yeah you could call it
competitor analysis if you'd like
whatever you'd like to say
first engineer the competitors
competitor competitor analysis
okay okay and this is we have
this is so far what we have guys reverse
engineering
google patents and then reverse entering
the competitor analysis
okay all right and then what it is is we
do
even deeper keyword analysis so what you
do number three is you know
deep work deeper keyword analysis so
essentially we're
taking the keywords that we want to rank
for right
and then what we're doing is we're
plugging that into our software
and it spits out a list of other
keywords that are related to that that
also
have high search volume and we cherry
pick the keywords are the dna of your
business online
right the deoxyribonucleic acid of your
business the keywords
the keywords are the bridge between the
money which is the customer and you
which is your website right and so
the whole idea is to find as many
keywords as we possibly can
that have transactional intention or
whichever intent you'd like them to take
sometimes people do it for passion
projects i also do uh
reputation management where someone has
a bad review or something on the first
page
and they pay me to take it off um
so that's a little different and you
have the key
that you just said here is keyword
yeah and so interesting now here's the
thing okay so let's
go through the example because this is
going to be important can we if we can
go through the example
so we have simulation
we can say the show around uncovering
the nature of reality consciousness and
accessing potential
top competitors and so uh
well maybe yeah i would say maybe right
now
that's a good one i would say right now
probably
the the podcasts that are most aligned
with what we're aligned with are
probably
the jerrogan experience eric weinstein's
portal
and lex friedman's ai podcast yeah i
would say those are probably the three
let's say for now yeah so we take alex
friedman's website and we just reverse
engineer what are the
how's he getting all of his traffic how
is he getting all these viewers
it's all i use this software called sem
rush
and sem rush is a uh you know it's a
tool it's the most industrial seo tool
you can get
basically with this stuff and you just
put in your your website or your
competitor's website and it gives you a
whole list of keywords that that's
bringing them in traffic what was that
tool called sem
and you also use it not for just
competitive analysis you use it for the
keyword analysis you use it for both
yes you can type in a website or any
keyword and it's going to spit out a
whole entire list of keywords that
have you know that that are very similar
to that that also have
uh the intent behind it that you'd like
and also high search volume
okay those are the two magical
ingredients for keywords
the you know the intention behind the
keyword and the uh the search volume
meaning how many people are searching
for it per month
okay and then what we do now and so what
would be
the word let's say would be something
like you can actually even run for the
word lex friedman
yeah or or let's say let's say the word
would probably be something a little bit
more like consciousness
or god or exploration or yeah
ai or um ancient hermetic principles
yeah yeah but so what you would find is
literally you're
are you saying that literally in this d
word deeper keyword analysis
you would find that they've done
a good amount of work already on
on another example would be let's say
the cameras or the mics
or the lights the companies that make
those if i'm making a new
camera what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go to the different
canons and nikons their websites and i'm
going to identify what
their keywords are that they've already
spent
millions of dollars in years of time in
years of time
when somebody types in best camera
the best dslr all this different type of
best lens
that's consciousness podcast best
consciousness podcast interesting
best podcast even you can keep it
podcast interesting and so
and so then would would then simply so
what we what we would have to do
in order to get simulation or the camera
company or whoever
up the new one it's only three years old
one year old etc
they would need to as like number one
is they would want sites that are
already
have a high ranking to do things like
link to simulation with
best podcast written in like their blog
post or whatever exactly
something like that exactly and so so
once we've done these three steps we're
going to have a big list of keywords
right
and remember that's the the bridge
between the customer and ourselves
so what we do with this big list of
keywords they say that um
if opportunity doesn't knock we must
build the door so what do we do
will you go back to the diagram yeah one
that we created yeah
so essentially the you know the whole
left side of the diagram is that first
box maybe you can draw like a little box
it says on page seo right there
like going down let me get the i'm just
gonna get
a quick a quick reset on the ndi
scan converter so i can get it to
re-read our new change let's make sure
it does okay there it is
okay so now we're going to go back to
your shot okay there we go so now
this is on the uh gash or no dash
dot com website well yeah i mean that's
one of our sites but the thing is right
here is what we're looking at
is the this the uh vertical line going
down where it says on page seo at the
top
and see how it goes down it says client
website landing page keyword one yeah
right
website you know landing page keyword
too and then keeps going down so that's
yeah so
we're gonna yeah so you can just draw
like a box around it or
whatever the case is it's probably best
actually for me to oh
i can't even either way it doesn't
matter maybe i can save the image to
help quick
yeah so the whole point is
okay so so why are you pointing
out of everything first is that your
point is that you're pointing at
at this box up here
yeah yeah well what i'm saying is like
that's what we're talking about right
now
this is what we've been talking about
exactly so what we're going to do this
procedure so we're left with a big list
of keywords right
okay so if opportunity doesn't knock we
must build a door so what do we do we
build
a door or build a landing page on the on
the client's website
optimize for each keyword so
we have to keep it in the url title and
you know we make sure that the keywords
in the right places interesting so
does that mean that
the like on simulation series dot com
that we would write literally the best
consciousness
podcast so what you want to do is your
url if if it was like best podcast
it would be you know simulation series
dot com slash best podcast
the next and then whatever the keyword
is that's what it is okay oh i see
okay so what so so would i would would
it be fair to say that
what you would want to do is you would
want to create additional
pages yes of course that's the thing if
you don't have pages on your website
optimized for those keywords good luck
ranking for it like exactly that's like
saying that's
and then i'll add the wood it's like no
you have to get the wood i see okay so
this is actually a really profound
realization then
is that then the number one
most simple thing for people to do that
have their north star pursuits in terms
of seo
would be just simply whatever the main
keyword is if it's best camera
uh best smoothie whatever it is whatever
it is
you need to make your you need to make
your like our friends
over at vitalis sarah she would need to
literally on her superfood
website she would literally need to
backslash
best smoothie and make a whole page
about why her smoothies are the best and
then
on the camera website it would be
backslash best camera
and then a whole bunch of content around
why our camera is the best
so simulation would need a backslash
best podcast and then the reasons why
because we cover all these topics yes
okay so this is the number one another
point you can make a lot of money by
referring me seo clients you know
bro but anyways that's the thing there's
so many epic people that walk in through
that door and the first thing
that we're going to say is you know how
dude wanna be on page one or one hundred
pages i mean it really doesn't matter to
me i'm fine either way you know
it's up to you but especially if the
ideas are good then they deserve the
memetic
spread and dessert there you
we believe that inside each and every
individual and lies a
a wonderful you know idea uh
or you know um service or product
right so every idea service or product
we basically take that
and we broadcast it to the rest of the
world we're an amplification device you
know we're
we're the traffic guys we're the
lifeblood of the business we're the guys
that bring you the customers we're the
most
you know vital part of business yeah
otherwise i'd be doing something else
yeah you know
and this is one of the seo wasn't it i
rewrote neuroscience with the founder of
the god particle dr katsushi arasaka
i consider myself you know not the
smartest this is the higgs boson
the most stupid and i'm just telling you
right now that if the the reason why i'm
in seo
neuroscience we rewrote neuroscience
with the founder of the god particularly
because
of the identification of the higgs boson
there was no no no he just happened to
find the god particle the higgs boson
doctor
well because it was a completely
separate thing i'm just letting you know
who the individual was oh yeah okay okay
it was due to the microcyclic eye
movements and corollary discharge
between central pattern generators
which we can cover later but just to
stay on topic sure
um so we we create a unique landing page
for each individual keyword right
got it and then what we do is we then
apply our back linking strategy so then
all those wonderful domains that we
talked about what is that called again
it's called the
create individual yeah create unique
landing pages create unique landing
pages for each keyword
exactly okay now you're speaking like an
seo
unique we're actually in like like this
is just what i found over 10 years i
don't know if like there's
other people out there that do it like
exactly like this or whatever but
you know like i just do what works for
me
so this is beautiful yeah this is
spotify and so the whole idea is you
want to own
you want to own a larger percentage of
the internet so the whole idea is
so the whole idea is you want to
dominate this your market organically so
you want to
take every keyword that has high search
volume and
transactional intention and you want to
have you know hundreds if not thousands
if not hundreds of thousands of pages
optimized for every single keyword in
the book
interesting so you actually would go as
far as to build
way more than just five pages that's why
it says you would
yeah so so we would we would take
consciousness as one best podcast as
another science spirituality
nature metaphysics transformation
transformational leadership
i mean literally keywords you want okay
but then
but then i literally need to make that
many pieces of unique
content as pages around those keywords
but the thing is super worth it i just
go
because anytime somebody looks up best
consciousness podcast they're going to
see me because i've done this process
yes or you just and that's
like your whole goal isn't to sit there
and just write a million pages your
whole goal is to
you know tell the writers what you want
and then they write it and then you
overlook it and then just post it to
your website
you know otherwise you're going to spend
in you know now until you die you're
writing articles and i doubt that's a
good use of your time
you know so hiring writers for this
process yeah yeah
go to ineedarticles.com um and it's
literally like
it's literally like five or ten dollars
an article you're not gonna
you won't be stressing too bad
interesting i need articles.com
yeah exactly okay so so it's fiverr it's
like five or somebody
you'll pay five or ten bucks someone
will write an article on consciousness
exactly
interesting okay and you can you can
send them other articles
of your competitors and say i want you
to write it something like this oh
that's
this level of professionalism but make
it different you know that's great
so now continuous along this
this journey of yeah because i like to
keep things super simple so basically
like
yeah yeah specifically so really that
the whole left
side of the diagram is just creating
those unique pages
and then those relevant linking domains
that we link and then as a result the
qualified and targeted traffic comes in
um the whole right side of the dart of
the diagram
is what you do once they're on the
website so you capture their email
address as it says
right and then you can also mix in some
paid traffic and some influencer
marketing and pr
and all of this and then you're just
capturing their information
their email address where you can
continuously remarket to them
forever without spending a dime on
advertising and so the return on
investment becomes astronomically
exponential
and you can use facebook messenger chat
dm bots and all this stuff which has a
way higher open rate over 90
more than uh you know email email
exactly
facebook messenger chatbots and not only
that but you do sms
text message campaigns actually those
are the biggest right now everybody's
like
yo text me and then they're putting
their phone number
that is the campaign because they want
to collect the phone numbers which gets
the highest physical addresses you can
send out direct mail as well direct mail
is really cheap
there's all these different stuff that
you can do once they're there but we
focus on
getting them the right yeah we're not a
sales agency
you're not a paid advertising agency we
are a pr agency in social media agency
but our main focus is seo
so that's what matters the most so then
in a sense you have something like
the yeah so then you have like the
the seo that's acting as the
the funnel and then what you get yeah
from there it's up to you whatever yeah
from yeah from here is then you have
your
get there you know get them in the sms
community
get them on the email physical address
for direct mail
physical address yeah
um and then the facebook chat bots
yeah and then also you could just go
straight up direct to sale you just take
them through a landing page or checkout
page and
sell them whatever you're trying to sell
them you know yep direct to sale
so you can do any of that stuff
interesting
and then what you're doing is you're
creating an asset so sc perpetually
generating residual income
for life while you're sleeping because
each one of these landing pages
is like its own salesman if you were to
go hire some salesmen for your company
right now
those salesmen have to sleep eight hours
a night those salesmen have to eat
those salesmen need time off those
salesmen you have to pay more for them
and you have to do all this stuff
each landing page we're creating is like
a digital
salesman that does not need to sleep
that does not do anything
um except conduct transactions 100 of
the time while you're sleeping
and uh you wake up and there's more
money in your bank account you know
it's you auto click and then all of a
sudden bank accounts full you know
not necessarily but my friend gave me an
inside joke that said that so i kind of
stuck with it but i love that so then
the
the idea like kind of like just like
with our
um content here on the show
is that what occurs is that over time as
we build out all these keyword pages
we funnel more and more people and in
the sense of like what we have with the
show is that once we have
i think somewhere around 1400 videos in
our content library
is now those make us advertising revenue
people watch them around the world
as we sleep and you get new customers
into the funnel as you see what you do
is you embed the youtube
because youtube's owned by google right
so what you do is you embed the youtube
video on your landing pages
optimize for those keywords and then
when you build links to that page since
the youtube video is embedded in that
page
and you put the keyword you want to rank
for in the title of the youtube video
and in the description and you tag it
with that keyword
then you're going to rank the youtube
video on the first page of youtube as
well
as ranking the website so it's like a
two okay one deal wouldn't
that would be something that along the
lines of every single
one of the con the youtube videos would
need its own page
so that way like joshua would have his
page for
piercing the veil of reality and then we
would have when somebody searches
piercing the veil of reality that this
would show up
as one of the top because there's also a
page for it
i'm following especially one of the
things that i really wanted to do
approximately
two plus years ago almost three years
ago now when we were first starting the
show
is i wanted to actually have
specifically
pages for each playlist topic like
biotech neurotech blockchain crypto
geopolitics eq spirituality
ins philosophy etc and then whenever
somebody would look up
podcast philosophy boom we would show a
podcast blockchain
boom we would show up and it would be
all of our you know because i filter
these into playlists so when somebody
wants to find
videos on blockchain they just go to our
blockchain playlist and there's
over a hundred interviews there like it
sounds like you could use some seo
i know a guy actually that doesn't i'm
just kidding would he by chance be
sitting across from me
i know but honestly yeah and then
another little house interesting when
you embed that youtube video on your
um website you can change the code of
the youtube video to where it auto plays
so as soon as they land yep on the
the web page it automatically plays the
video and then that actually gives you a
view
or account towards the count uh view
algorithm
in youtube which also helps you rank in
youtube as well yep so there's another
little hack you can do
yeah yeah uh that's this has been
really fruitful hopefully for a lot of
people because if
because if we're not focusing on
specifically this
funnel as you described oh yeah you're
ignoring 97
of them 97 and then they want to ignore
97
and then this other aspect to it i think
is super rich
which is basically that you must do
this keyword analysis yeah and then when
you find those keywords
then you make those unique landing pages
for each of those keywords
based on those keywords based on what
your business
is about yeah no matter what the keyword
is no matter what the keyword is that's
yeah
wow it's it's like the reason why you're
launching people off google controls
google controls the world's information
and essentially as an seo you control
google
and so whoever controls the world's
information controls the world so that's
why i got into seo
because i knew that if i just mastered
this one
skill i knew that i could literally
create an endless amount of impact and
not only that yeah
in the real estate business you're
limited to real estate in the
cryptocurrency business you're limited
to crypto and the
you know art painting business you're
limited to painting but seo is something
that transcends every industry so i can
infinitely scale
exponentially and transcend every
industry and make a ridiculous amount of
money
not that that's you know the goal
necessarily that's just the byproduct of
a job well done and yeah purpose and
everything
and then you you know step one survive
step two throughout okay now my question
to you is we
unpacked all of the juiciness of the seo
as much as we could on the macro
star level concept now where are you
funneling
as you gain this incredible monetary
mechanism
for you and also helping people thrive
with their ideas in the sense
now what's your thrive this was the
survive
thrive is the passion yeah you know so
you have the profit and you have the
passion and some people are lucky enough
to you know make money off their
passions yeah yeah but the thing is
there's
other industries out there
what are your other my passion is music
philosophy
um you know esotericism uh
science mathematics um just like you
basically yeah
and but what do you want to do with all
those passion spaces like so my main
goal
right before covet 19 right was
um you know just become you know
more in the entertainment industry so an
actor of course
a producer and then music as well you
know so i wanted to be
you know a musician i mean i'm not going
to say wanted to be i am a musician you
know what i meant just further my career
and then i started you know writing some
songs and samples for this group called
1500 or nothing
and they're the producers for like
justin timberlake and drake and bruno
mars and
you know like i've worked with like
drake's manager and like
i'm involved in this project with the
founder of the entertainment channel and
like there's just so much stuff i mean i
can go down the list forever
but i'm not here to you know harp about
that but at the macro level like you
said it's entertainment
you know okay that's what wyatt earp
actually did too
is um he basically the first movies were
western movies right
and he was a consultant for the the top
in the biggest movie studios in the
world you know
because they needed somebody on set that
knew something about the real wild west
so that they could advise and help make
the movies better
so that's ironically enough like this is
all you know stuff that i found out
later in life and i'm just like holy cow
i had no idea
that he was born in illinois and moved
to l.a and died and now there's this
place called erp california and
he was an advisor to all the biggest
guys in entertainment and then i'm just
looking at my life and what i'm doing
and i'm just like
holy cow the synchronicities yeah yeah
exactly subconscious secrets
that sounds like a good podcast name
subconscious synchronicities
there you go i love it that's awesome
so it was just destiny unfolding itself
you know and sometimes the last thing is
sometimes you have to give up the life
that you've planned
in order to accept the life that is
waiting for you
would would it be fair to say that your
focus
now is on specifically
entertainment as well as seo so yeah so
still seo
but entertainment and then acting
producing
music i would just say business because
i operate in the entrepreneurial
business space yes
and i also operate in the entertainment
space and there's so there's the
business world got it then there's the
entertainment world and then there's the
entertainment business world for sure so
there's for sure three different worlds
that i'm pretty much operating in got it
got it and now it would be also fair to
say that
then what would you like to
act or produce or music
or entrepreneurship business no
understanding it was going to give me my
own television show because i do magic
and mentalism and
you know i've done some you know i
originally started out as a background
actor and then i worked my way up from
there and now
i'm working with the producers for like
adam sandler and like i said we were on
the phone before this call you got to
hear a little bit of it and
you know he discovered him and produced
his first movie and is
doing all this big stuff and he's going
to put me in some other stuff
and i'm helping him with the marketing
and stuff there's ins everywhere you
know yeah
um but essentially like disney wanted to
give me i was acting on a show at the
the disney lot and um you know i was
afterwards we were all hanging out and i
was showing the celebrities like you
know magic and mentalism
and it blew their mind and then it got
hold of the producers blew their mind
that
there was this guy that could predict
some weird event that happened when they
were six years old they never told
anyone about
okay let's do it we gotta do it at the
end this is just closing yeah trust me
it's a close
closer okay but no but here's the thing
though is um and you're gonna yourself
gonna be amazed like like when you
re-watch the video you
look at your own face seriously um but
anyway so check this out though
so um so anyway yeah and then
you know basically the producer said hey
look
we want to meet you at this coffee shop
at this time and we're going to
create a tv show based on your life
where you go around and show
magic to all these celebrities or
whatever and i said that sounds great
and then bam
covet 19 baby and then then i just it
got
it you know kind of took me in the world
by storm and then so i decided to shift
my focus and align my focus towards more
on the business side then i became a
very heavy precious metals investor
and cryptocurrency investor which i was
already doing that before but
i'm i'm really smart man with my asset
allocations you know in terms of
percentages and
hedging you know against inflation
hedging them against each other
we can go over all that stuff maybe at a
different time but
so then would it would it also be fair
to say that then
within the the
entrepreneurship entertainment space the
business entertainment space that
one of the things that you care about
which we care about so much
is that we want to create a more
awakening
in los angeles exactly okay exactly um
you know la we live in the belly of the
beast that's why i don't mind kicking it
in the stomach every once in a while you
know
but the whole in la is like you know
it's like a barber shop you know if you
hang around the barbershop long enough
eventually you get a haircut and so it's
so the whole thing is like my goal is to
create you know like you said the
awakening
right but also you know inspirational
messages as well that's right that's
what my
best friend adam sandler's producer
we're really really into that stuff like
if it's like a horror movie or whatever
like we just don't touch it
um but if it's inspirational and
uplifting which the word inspiration
comes from the word inspire which means
to breathe
so if you right
that's respiration inspiration
in spirit okay the word spirit comes
from the word spire the respiratory
system that's why we have that there
and dmt is the spirit molecule right the
most dmt is produced not in our pineal
gland
um but during our in our lungs during
conscious breathing
and in reptiles they have a retina
cornea and a lens
so it literally is their pineal gland
literally is their third eye but
what i was going to say is that the word
conspiracy
or conspire means to come together and
to breathe
and so um so once you understand all
this stuff you know it um
becomes very inspirational you know yeah
we want to breathe life into people we
want you
the moment you stop breathing the spirit
is the breath the moment you stop
breathing
uh you know your spirit leaves your body
so
essentially that's what we want to do we
want to be the catalyst and spark of
change you know that uh ignites the
world and the cool thing is
is you know if we have a you know a
torch right that's lit
we can go and light pretty much
everyone's torch without diminishing our
flames
that's what we're trying to do that's it
without the word try that's it that's it
i love that analogy that one's super
rich
the torch such a good one yeah and
specifically i like how you say that
it's both about
awakening and inspiration because
awakening is like the self-realization
to the unity of all being in existence
and then there's the self-actualization
which is like the inspiration for people
to
rock it off and identify those north
stars and actualize those gifts into the
world i love that that's really strong
so then okay so i'm i'm following now
i like this i like this it seems like
there's a lot of uh
a lot of synthesis yet between our
essences
on what both of us are aiming to
catalyze here which
we will be doing more of together
ridiculously pumped for that now
before we get into the it sounds like
you want to do the mentalism stuff at
the end
so then okay and by the way just because
of
the cameras and angles and things like
that we may want to make sure that we
capture the true essence of the
mentalism
i may have to stand over here so we may
want to do that as a separate
clip that we just you know cut into the
video at the end however you want to do
it but just realize that with
cameras here here here we're not going
to be able to see it the right way so
let's try it at the end i can do
something probably with a deck of tarot
cards or something with a deck of cards
i think
i brought a deck of regular cards oh
okay so i might be able to do that but
then the other thing is um
there are none that we can do without
the deck of is there anything that we
can do
just oh yeah well of course well it's
not the deck of cards is just a medium
everything we're gonna do is in our mind
right
but we can do it definitely without but
we're just saying the camera angles
yeah right we're not going to be able to
see the phone i'm following i'm
following so we'll
we'll see whatever we can unfold for
people at the end
and then if we and and later for round
two
if i can just face this way so you can
actually see what i'm doing then that
would work well you
we already have this okay so if we can
only look from this
camera so that they can actually see it
well then we then that would be
effective if we can't look from just
this camera then it's not going okay
okay but what about what about this what
what about this angle where they can see
from your angle
and from my reactions to what you're
doing and from the center shot
okay so the only way it's going to work
is if it's this camera
only and then if you want to show a
reaction you just turn your head towards
the camera or
this camera only it just can't be
anything right here okay
but then they're just going to miss it
but if they're looking
right here at this top right there
you're shopping at me from the side
which one are you referring to i'm
i'm if you look in the quad shop the
lower right yeah yeah the quad shot
right is no good okay but the upper left
corner is where they're gonna be
fine yeah but that's where they're going
to be looking but that way they can see
my reaction to what you're saying
whatever you want to do as
long as there's no side shot in the
upper right hand corner of that
oh you don't you don't want the two shot
there oh
you don't want the two shot you don't
want that center shot
interesting okay yeah because well the
thing is because the experiment they're
not going to be able to see it we want
to make sure they can okay
so something like something like this
yeah like on the quad yeah if we can do
that then that's good
yeah yeah i see so just not that yeah
i'm following
i'm gonna turn this camera off we don't
have to turn it off we can just have it
like
well the thing is i'm the mentalist
right so we do need to turn it off
but you mean like you mean like this
right there you go yeah as long as like
you can't re-watch from this camera that
it will be off that's right it'll be off
it'll just be
you yes because you have to see it from
a pure perspective
okay and because what we're doing is
inside of the mind okay
and so can we launch into it um or do we
want to save this for them because we're
already ready for it yeah so let's go
ahead and just do the mentalism
let's do it yeah we're at the end right
so well because we're saving it for the
end so
but we should also talk i still want to
talk we still have some other things
to talk okay so yeah we'll
confidentialism now it doesn't really
matter okay let's do it now yeah
so what i'm gonna do is um
i want you to go ahead i usually do this
standing up is that that's probably not
possible in this situation right so
we'll go ahead and do it like this
okay so what i want you to do is i want
you to think
so i'm going to need to use my hands and
stuff but i'll lean in
so what i want you to do is i want you
to think um
and we kind of do need it to be um
like full view is there any way we could
take that camera and make it down a
little bit so you can see my hands like
if i'm down here you can't see what i'm
doing down here hmm
yeah yeah i can see that's there anyway
yeah yeah one second let me let me just
zoom out
i'll just zoom out of that shot
yeah we're going to want to zoom out
quite a bit because my hands are all
invisible right now so
so there we go that should be good
okay and is is that okay then yeah that
on the left that's not okay because it's
seeing me right here see
do you see where my finger's pointing
lower left
you yeah but you're so basically this
needs to go no i know they're not seeing
that okay yeah yeah
oh i'm just you can't rewatch no no
nobody's nobody
no you there's that's not even recording
no nothing it's only only
the program i'm saying this in a second
yeah okay only otherwise you're going to
miss it
the only thing is that program feed
which is in the bottom right corner so
that that
that's not even that's not even
recording the yeah so yeah so we're
going to do the mentalism experiment now
in order for for you to
witness the mentalism we have to i'm
going to do two things okay one will be
with
either a deck of tarot cards or a deck
of regular cards it doesn't matter it
has to be a medium right
the second one is going to be pure and
it's all in the mind but it's purely
going to be
uh in the mind okay so the first one
okay so what i want you to do i think
i've got a uh
deck of cards let me see really quickly
okay now i do um
i want you to hold on to it okay okay
now
should i unfortunately should i zoom out
of my shot too um it doesn't matter okay
okay um so the whole thing is
is um mentalism is an ancient occult
science okay it's a divinatory science
it's of divination right
i usually use tarot cards i didn't have
any laying around so i brought those
but i made a prediction okay so i took
one card and i turned it face down in
the middle of the deck
okay and um i basically just made a
prediction that's all i did it's kind of
like the lord of the rings there can be
only one right
okay now the oldest transmitting and
receiving station is not the radio
or the television it's the human mind
yep so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to think of the card that i turned down
okay
or and what i'm going to do is i'm going
to transmit it to you
mentally okay so what's what's going to
happen is you're going to
start to see a card that appears in your
mind okay and
not the ace of spades or anything or
anything obvious like that it's gonna be
random okay did you pick up on it
i think i did okay so what was the card
that you were thinking
the four of diamonds four of diamonds
now
let's see the cards okay so what i'm
gonna have you do
there's one card there's one face down
yeah go ahead and
hold the card or the deck so like i said
every single card is
face up except for one shot coming to
the shot
sorry yeah either way go ahead and take
that card out and tell me
which one it was that's why i was
telling you to zoom out and show them
what was it
was the four of diamonds thank you you
can put it back
and so now you might be thinking okay
well that was uh i'll take this back too
if you don't mind
now you might be thinking okay well that
was a one in 52
chance right so they're like well i'm
thinking some other stuff but
what do you think i'm thinking that
there was a perfect amount of
time for me to look over to
make sure that the cards were in the
shot when they were actually under
yeah that's why i told you to zoom out
in the beginning so it is what it is but
yeah the next one will be
without a deck of cards okay okay so
that's i just do this to warm up okay so
so the whole thing is is uh that's a one
in a 52
chance right so it's like it's amazing
but it's not like
you know godly amazing right correct
one in fifty two well i mean i have to
review and we'll see if you get it well
i
i'm it's also yeah curious if when
it happens with somebody live where
there's not needing to stay in the
actual angle of the shot because
you can also hear what sounds like the
card flipping over
and stuff like that but yeah i mean i'm
just like this is the whole mentalism
thing let's do it one more time
within the shot okay so i'll turn a
different card face down which i
actually already did go ahead and hold
the cards
oh you already did yeah i already did it
trust me you already did it yes
trust me okay i know it might be hard
for you to do it but just do it
okay so this time but listen though it's
only because i might have turned two
face down um because i had an idea i was
gonna do another card now this time
okay what i want you to do is i'm gonna
send the card to you again
okay okay so and i want you to really
watch my hands when i do this okay so
look
boom what is the card
it's the nine of hearts now do you want
to keep the knight of hearts or change
it
i want to keep it okay nine of hearts
okay so let's make sure it stays on
yeah i see it's in the shot okay that
top left all right i'll do it like this
you're still in the shop okay you're
still in the nine of hearts
right uh-huh so inside the shots every
single
card is face up except for one uh-huh
yeah what card do you think that is go
ahead and pull it out
boom that's the nine of hearts you can
put it back and is i'm just curious
about that that was that was profound
where's the i'm just curious there's the
three of diamonds
that was that was that was very cool so
i'll turn that card over again just in
case someone else says three or five
now once again nine of hearts yeah yeah
or whatever it was
yeah see i don't even know but it works
every time even i don't know okay
that was really interesting because it
did happen yeah that one that one was
more clear to me because that first one
i was checking to see if it was in the
shot or not
yeah was that this is not this last one
foolery like you know
slight of hand or anything okay this is
like just as real as you can get
re-watch the one that is in the shot and
you'll see exactly that it's real okay
now you might be thinking okay that's
one in a 52 chance okay which is amazing
but once again it's not
god awfully amazed now we're not going
to use any cards at all and instead of a
one in 52 chance
we're gonna do a one and infinity chance
okay
so what i want you to do is i want you
to
now you saw how i transmitted
the thought to you and you picked up on
it right now may i ask a question
was that a continuous
energetic repetition of said card nine
of hearts
he's going to pick the knight of hearts
and nine of hearts has been transmitted
to you and then it
you know it's just mentalism it's an
ancient occultic divinatory science so
it's divination and energy does play a
role but also
um you know it is what it is you're not
going to reveal that there was a
process of you transmitting the well it
might have been neuro linguistic
programming i might have
subconsciously influenced you there's a
lot of possibilities right okay
um i must say it's pretty cool for sure
well that's that's nothing
and that's what that's sort of what the
david blaine style
schools of yeah thinking are yeah so
they make people really excited yeah so
here's the thing okay
so now like i said we're not gonna do
any deck of cards okay
i just did that as a warm up to show you
what's possible okay okay so now it's a
one and an infinity
chance i heard you're gonna only from
one in 52 to one infinity chance this is
going to
be right yeah exactly so so you saw how
i you know the transmission
reception i i transmitted it to you and
you received it
correct now it was kind of interesting
it was like almost like uh
it like kind of in a sense
like out of the 52 it's interesting
out of the one and out of the
52 and 52 it it
it out of the 52 options
it felt like as you were
coming to the point where you were gonna
snap it like kind of
funneled down to maybe four and then it
funneled down to two
and then it funneled down to that last
one yeah yeah it was kind of interesting
that that process happens yeah
so here's the crazy part so
you know nostradamus would always you
know write something down it would
always come true
correct well i'm kind of like a
modern-day nostradamus
okay so you saw how
i transmitted to you the thought of the
playing card right
now this time you're gonna think of a
number between one and
infinity okay okay in your mind okay
don't make it to anything ridiculous
like i had one guy say
one trillion nine hundred and sixty four
thousand i mean when i read what's wrong
with that well i mean when i
when i read you can do it but i'm just
saying like i um
i did the the um founder of ethereum uh
read his mind and he he said two to the
256
power and he was just amazed that i knew
that information he's just like how the
hell did you understand that
you know so it can be something
incredibly complex but also simple can
be harder than complex what i'm saying
is just don't
i have to i'm going to write it down
i'll make my prediction i'm just saying
don't make me write too much pick any
number whatever you want to pick but
it's just don't make it like
you can make it as ridiculous as you
want but even if it's just the number
one are you kidding me one infinity what
are the odds of that
okay what does that face
i can tell that there's a that mentalism
that's happening you know it's like yeah
yeah
don't pick seven trillion you know you
can pick something that's like seven
because you know that it could be
anything you want you know i can tell
though there's that
there's really no there's that secret
sauce you know
you have your mind blank there is no
secret sauce on this one
i'm just saying it's it's something that
i've picked up from watching other
mentalists
over time is that they do this they do
this process that
some other mentalist effect you know
like you'll see what i mean i mean you
guys are honing on a similar skill david
blainely or suchard
joshua erp you're honing honestly i
studied under the best mentalist in the
world banach
uh richard osterlund all the greatest
you know and then i ended up surpassing
them actually because i've just
you know that's the way students should
be okay all right let's do this so
here's the thing
any number from one to pretend i never
said anything at all okay
sure blank slate we just met okay how
are you doing hi how are you
think of a number between one and
infinity seriously i don't want you to
think i'm just giving you other examples
don't let me influence you in any way
okay
you have the number in your mind huh
let's see here
yeah got it see what you're doing right
there is you're displaying rapid eye
movement which means you're hypnotized
right now
okay in fact rem rapid eye movement is
when the brain releases the most dmt
and um that's the number one way you can
tell if someone's hypnotized is because
they demonstrate rem so right now and
all hypnosis is
is the moment that you become 100
absorbed into something
whenever someone's talking whenever
something's you know you're like
you got me to do the number from one to
infinity and during that time you could
see rem happening
yes okay so anyway which you can if you
look at your partner sleeping or your
parents sleeping you can kind of
begin seeing that under yeah it's cool
so what i'm gonna do is just like
nostradamus
okay i'm going to write down a
prediction okay and i usually have a um
like a notebook or i'll usually oh you
want to put it on this i think i
no it's okay i think i brought something
that's easier to write on just more
handheld
i love it i dreamed the brothers got a
notebook
and a sharpie along with his deck of
cards
on deck yeah on deck he brought it
that's when you know you're dealing with
the real men with a real mentalist
that's right
they come prepared you know yeah exactly
so what i want you to do is you're
thinking of that specific
um okay i'm gonna make a prediction okay
i didn't i'm not gonna choose some crazy
like long one i'm just gonna
oh my gosh here we go do you have to
look at my eyes
uh and not really because i can already
it's the vibration so
okay just go along with it all right
anybody can resist anything just go
along with it
take some takes more intellect to go
along with something all right so here
we go
so i made my predictions if you don't
mind hold the just
yeah just hold it i mean unless you have
a table but yeah okay now what i want
you to do is i made my prediction i
apologize i write literally like a
freaking doctor so i apologize
now what i want you to do is play the
role of the alchemist
okay just let it go don't fidget with it
all right now look
what i want you to do is play the role
of the alchemist okay
just hold it down it's not going
anywhere play the role of alchemist okay
and instead of transmuting you know base
metals into gold or the human soul to a
divine soul i want you to transmute it
from the mental
to the physical so now that i've already
made my prediction
i want you to let everyone know
including my partner naeem in the back
and everyone watching
what was the number you were thinking of
it doesn't even matter at this point but
it does matter because we need to see it
on that sheet of paper though
see that's why i said go along with
you're not listening to the instructions
you're supposed to
you're ruining the vibration you're
supposed to name you're supposed to play
the role of the alchemist and name the
number
if you can't name the number we won't do
it it's fine but you're supposed to
i made my prediction i want you to go
you made the prediction did you not see
me writing
okay you're asking too many questions
the bet the next thing coming out of
your mouth better be a number and we're
not doing it okay
all right okay the number that's called
the heckler by the way when you're
dealing with someone that's different
well no it's just trying to
prove the you know the the proof will be
in the pudding so what is the sure
okay you have to play the role of the
okay first schrodinger's cat quantum
mechanics okay what's the number
the number is 79 trillion
so you put 79 trillion 888 billion
888 billion and four
are you serious that's the number i
picked yeah
and then in four now is there a reason
why you chose four or
at the end of it yeah well because i
wanted to have at least
one more number that was non-zero so i
told you don't pick the most ridiculous
one but you pick the most ridiculous one
now what's crazy is so
so look look check this out like i said
my handwriting is horrible but if we
turn it around go ahead and check this
out
i'll take the pen back if you don't like
okay check it out you can see
look look 79 read it again out loud so
they can see it
i know it's horrible handwriting i've
since i was a little kid i've had bad
handwriting
but read it what does it say 79
trill there's a seven and a nine it does
appear like there's a seven and a nine
and then
trill which is a horrible handwriting
and then what's underneath trill on the
next line under
so i can actually show and then there's
three eights i can see it
i can see there's three there's three
eighths i can see that
eight eight eight wait let's see and it
looks like bill
it does look like the word bill right
here il
and then what four but the thing wasn't
really that long
seven it looks like seven nine it could
be a two though
it's still really impressive that it got
to this level and it looks like there
could be a four
here what was it that you said okay
seven nine okay that is irrefutable
seven nine bill b-i-l i do see that okay
yep
eight eight eight okay bill okay
bill yep and four but i i didn't go
down i see yeah yep
that's really impressive and so that is
very that's very
impressive it's like it's not like you
just said four and then like you know
like this is the closest that you can
get to actually win
i just picked a random number that's
that's really impressive when you think
about the mathematical because i'm a
numbers guy right
that's a one in infinity so when you
think about the mathematical statistical
probability that's closer to that for
sure okay i mean it's definitely not
you know it definitely doesn't say that
it's not 79. no trillion yeah yeah
in it interpretation but it's a pretty
damn
close beautiful it's pretty damn close
yeah yeah actually it's super duper
impressive so
so would it would it be would it be fair
to say something like
there's a level of
it's just the akashic records so would
you say that there's some sort of
level of i mean is it okay to turn the
center shot oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i
just want to make sure you guys can see
everything because if not then it's
you know defeats the purpose okay so we
turn the sensor on that one in too if
you want
yeah so um
so it's you know and this is the same
thing albert einstein tapped into
with his universal thought experiments
um
you know it's kind of like the akashic
records in a sense of the universal
thought library of everything that ever
was
is or ever will be i you know pulled it
from the ether
um essentially and i went out on it on a
limb you know i didn't want to write all
the actual numbers so i
spelled a few out you know 79 trillion
888 billion
and four and you know i'll even in fact
let's do this too
i want to give you this piece of paper i
was gonna i was it's funny because i
literally just had that thought
like i want you to read it four seconds
ago i was like it would be fun to
potentially have that sheet of paper to
remind me
and then joshua goes i'll give you the
sheet of paper yeah yeah
i'm telling you though we're all
connected more than we think we are and
so like i said before
do not sleep on this the oldest
receiving
and transmitting station is not the
radio or the television it is the human
mind and the more people can understand
this
and access different parts of their mind
then they will be able to be more fully
equipped to
do whatever it is they're trying to do
you used the word
akashics a moment ago and i had a
question lined up for you that was
around that
it would be something along the lines of
i know you're gonna pick something like
that too i like before you ever said
anything
i was thinking i was like okay he's
definitely not gonna say four
but i think there's gonna be a four in
there so i was like okay four
he's gonna say the most random [ __ ]
because i mentioned trillion earlier so
i was like [ __ ] i gave him an idea i
don't want to
i was like so i got it right 79 trill
you know 888 bill which is irrefutable
go ahead and dissect that later on if
you want yeah yeah those are that's
pretty clear
those are yeah those are pretty
indistinguishable i mean like obviously
yes i have horrible handwriting i've had
that since i was a kid that's not going
to ever change
but the fact is it's definitely
think of any other number in the world
and tell me if it looks like that and
you'll say no
yeah you yeah so let's let's you just
said 64. like that's obviously not 16.
for sure
for sure for sure okay let's play with
this a little bit more so
would it be fair to say something along
the lines of there's a sensitivity
that enables a tapping in
that can take something like
asking somebody to come up with a number
from one to infinity
and that then
enables you to
process what that mind comes
up with it's um
the thing is is um channel it through to
the pen and the paper
it's just it's just mentalism you know
it's existed for thousands and thousands
of years you know it's called divination
it's what all these elite politicians
and all these [ __ ] you know
part of my french
um it's what they're doing they're
they're practicing divination they have
crystal balls they're
looking they're scrying into reflective
surfaces they're utilizing this
phenomenon
give you props my man some people it's
very good some people just use a higher
percentage of their brain than other
people
yeah and it doesn't make them you know
smarter or better there's probably some
sort again
of a tapping into that universal field
and that that's what nikola tess lives
in that's why he was a genius and just
calling that
through what that person comes up with
as that number down in
yeah and i mean there were some seeds
planted but
yeah i mean that definitely wasn't that
seed though i'll tell you that
i mean it was pretty interesting i
definitely wanted to one in infinity
just do the math i wanted to i did i
definitely wanted to
i won't yeah yeah it's true it's true um
okay let's uh let's i'm really grateful
that you did
that you did several mentalism
experiences
for me on the show and for the guests
and to the audience that was very
uh brave and i'm really grateful that
you did because it's a live stream
it does work you know it doesn't always
work that's another i mean the thing is
there's been plenty of times when i was
wrong
it's just me too me too i would
and it's funny we have you know we had
rupert sheldrick on the show recently
and
he's doing a lot of incredible work and
oh he's trying to prove this stuff what
is
he responsible for um the the more
resonates
in its field yeah or the morphonic field
or something right yeah yeah morphic
resonance
is in in a sense what we're explaining
here with mentalism in a sense
and so he's we're currently also trying
to help him
fund these studies through the rich
patrons site
and as we unlock ultra high net worth
families and individuals to funnel funds
into things like
his joint he can help with that we would
love that that'd be a good one
rupert would love that rupert would love
that as well and there's several studies
he's got a
a telephone telepathy study and a joint
attention
study and then i'm also trying to help
him build
a we should help him build this um we
came up with this idea while we were in
conversation on the show with rupert
which is to actually get millennials gen
z and generation alpha
involved in the type of stuff we're
talking about regarding that universal
field
through mobile games so as in this
how could it be that in this case what
we were talking about with rupert
if we had the same
puzzle that i was playing here in the
united states
and that somebody else played uh
right after i finished note
communication
none zero zero zero communication
and people were inside of those boxes no
communication is allowed i can't use the
device to do anything after i do the
puzzle
and i'm being supervised they're being
supervised and what you do is you have
basically a thousand people across the
planet go
one after the other in terms of speed of
finishing the puzzle
that are approximately the same level of
iq
yeah which is a faulty metric at best
it's a and but
at best we're trying to do something at
best so okay
so we have a hundred a thousand people
that are around in the center of the
bell curve of iq
yeah i think there's a lot of merit in
what you guys are doing and so that's a
good one to test because if it takes
me 60 seconds to finish the puzzle
and then it takes the last person in
australia or south africa thailand or
wherever they are across the planet
if it only takes them 20 seconds to
finish the puzzle and there's a very
steady decrease in the speed and there's
a thousand people that are also watching
the thousand people that are doing it to
ensure
right that there's no communication
there's and
so now we're talking about some
literally planetary
field right we're talking about that
mind field that universal
field scale caution energy that's scalar
like that
speaking of which so anyway the biggest
scale let's do this
let's i'm just saying let's do that one
i have a friend that
specifically that's all he does is you
know
influence these highly you know like uh
influential families let's just call it
that and extremely you know
um let's do it what is it called uh
yeah i mean that's all he does so i can
definitely connect with him
like generational wealth type families
you know we will we will and
so we need we've uh you i think you were
about to dive into this right by a
resident oh yeah obviously
one thing too is um yeah because that
ties in with the morpha
genetic field that's what it's called
right morphogenetic yeah morphogenetics
genetics resonance morphic fields yeah
yeah yeah so
so nikola tesla yeah um we have access
to a miniature
tesla coil that's also combined with
uh you know the work of galen hieronymus
which is uh you know the radionics
individual and we've created a
device that emanates scalar light or
scalar energy
at a reverse phase harmonic of whatever
vibration
is wrong with your body whether it be
you know
all these incurable diseases and all
this other stuff you know it's pretty
interesting
the work that we're doing there um but
bio it's kind of like bio resonance
therapy where
everything in nature has a frequency
that either helps it or destroys it
right and so the whole thing is with
bioresonance therapy which is a little
different than what i'm talking about
but
similar concepts is it basically reverse
engineers the frequency
that is you know emanated from your body
whether it be cancer or a
virus or bacteria or pathogen and it
simply takes that frequency through the
machine determines what frequency it is
and then it inverts that frequency
and then pushes it back into the body um
okay so there's a pathology that's
developing
inside of the body and it's at a certain
vibratory frequency
it's detected and then it's reverse
engineered they backtrack the frequency
and invert it it is harmonic
through a reverse phase harmonic and
then it's sent back into the body at
that same location
yes and then the tumor reverses yes
or the pathology reverses yeah bacteria
path uh pathogen or virus whatever the
case
for sure candida cancer okay so then
there's this basically this emergent
field of using
quantum biotechnology quantum biotech i
love it it's through quantum
entanglement it's um
the same way one cell phone can
communicate to another cell phone we can
remotely send scalar light energy to
anywhere in the world
um through the use of a photograph
because in the quantum world you don't
exist so
before we get into that let's back up a
little bit because some people are like
wait a second you rewrote neuroscience
with the founder of the god particle
and then i just did this crazy thing
where i read your mind and all this
stuff
so how is all this stuff related how
does it work well
so dr katsushira saka who created
the large hadron collider for cern in
geneva switzerland
he created all seven even the small
handheld ones all to the way to the
biggest ones you know
in cern he runs the largest direct
detection of dark matter experiments
such as xenon and dark side out of a
laboratory in sas of italy
which is the most expensive thing you
can get on this planet and also he um
he and i which it was mostly him i was
just cited on the paper
due to my incredibly deep insight in
neocortical phase integration
but he basically i can't take all the
credits mostly him
um what he did is is he basically has
this
machine this this um technology that can
track your
micro uh cicada eye movement so
basically if i were to read a book
right so check this out seriously if i
were to read a book
okay and my head could stay still
but my eyes are moving left to right
right that's called the cicade
okay so this machine tracks the micro
cicadic eye movement okay and combined
with the corollary discharge between
the central pattern generators of the
information processing between the eyes
and the brain okay and we found that
there's a couple milliseconds of a delay
between the information processing of
the outside world in the internal world
okay
and so what we discovered what he
discovered once again i was just cited
for my incredibly deep insight in
neocortical phase integration
what he discovered is that
um it's the excitation before the
inhibition
and so what that means is that it's not
our eyes that see what's around us
uh you know your average person would
think that we're just sitting in a room
and we're talking to each other and and
that's it
right but in reality right um
so what plays into that mentalism yes it
does play into a lot
but listen you're gonna really jive with
this i really think sure
because you're one of those few that are
smart enough to really understand this
you know
and of course your wonderful audience
and guests and everything yeah
now here's the thing so we found a
couple millisecond of delay between the
information processing of the brain and
the eyes okay so that literally
proved to us that it's the excitation
before the inhibition what that means is
that it's not our eyes that see what's
around us
and then broadcast that message to our
brain it's our brain that begins with
the
image first and then our eyes broadcast
outwards what's already inside of us and
this explains manifestation
counter factual simulation etc etc
and so it ties in also with the ancient
hermetic principles of
as within so without as above so below
and so it goes all the way back to
ancient hermeticus
another reason why it's so deeply
resonant is because
there's been a tremendous amount of
neuroscientists that have been trying to
understand
more and more whether
perception and even philosophers and
spiritualists
in the last thousands of years like you
were just describing a moment ago
whether perception can't work
in a sort of binary way nothing sort of
works in that style of a binary way it's
all a mix
so it can't possibly just be such a
binary statement
that i take in the sensory data
and that that's the way that it works no
i literally
have these a priori representations
of the way that reality is that then
mixes
with the perceptual intakes
and that that works in a dynamic
feedback
process feedback loop yeah that then
works with my
north star which is why we have that
style
which ties in with solipsism
which is the idea of the anything
outside of one's own mind is not sure to
exist
that's why we are the creative
expression of the universe experiencing
itself
now as i said earlier the u y o u
inverse but also the word
verse is in there as well we are in
space
verse meaning music meaning sound
meaning vibrations
even um pythagoras would would claim
that even the
heavens and the planetary um you know
stars and etc above had their own
orchestral type of sound you know so
it's all frequency number and vibration
i would make the argument that
as william t
powers said that
perception is absolutely fundamental
to reality and so
the way that you take we've mentioned
this throughout the show several times
your concepts the way that you
form your lattice work is absolutely
crucial
so that where you have your star located
and you have your fluid process around
how you're going to attain it
but that you also have that style of
future authoring that
intent and that lattice work of concepts
where
if you don't have a lattice work what
happens is that
there's this
less likelihood for the person to be
able to move as an
agent through the world with sovereignty
and with conceptual schemas that enable
them to actually maximize their own
flourishing and the flourishing of
others
and so i've noticed that that's a big
key it happened to me in 2020
that i put together high level
perception which ended up being a very
powerful latticework for me
that moving forward enables me to
funnel profound insights into
some sort of a further developmental
augmentation of this
north star trajectory latticework that
exists
without that there's a
but you have to be you have to be you
you you ha you can't allow the
lattice work to grip you like the
default mode network
obsessively compulsively never micro
dosing
to let go so all those profound new
connections can happen
because your lattice work can augment
over time
that type of stuff i agree i love that
that's a really good synthesis of those
last
couple points i like that a lot and
there's a lot one more time on the
field it's a it's like a quantum
biotechnology
is the field you know if you look at
curly and photography
right and you take a picture of the hand
then you'll see the energetic field
around the hand which i believe i could
be wrong i'm not familiar with mr
sheldrake's work but i believe it could
be something similar to what he's
discussing
some people call it an aura which is you
know a-u-r-a what's a you
you know that's gold in this uh
scientific uh scientific periodic table
of elements
and what's raw god yeah exactly raw amen
when you say amen at the end of a prayer
it's
amen or amen the sun god you know
and um but anyway so so if you look at
curly and photography right
and you just you know you can even pull
up a picture if you want or whatever
but um but essentially if you take it of
the hand you'll see it glowing
throughout the hand so just type in
curling photography k-i-r-l-i-a-n
photography and go to images and it
should be
um there see the hand right there on the
left
that one works too but anyway so it's
it's basically proving that yes we do
have this energy body
you can also take curling photography of
fruit and you'll see that it also has
its
everything has an energy field okay
absolutely and so the whole thing is
is that what we're able to do is in the
quantum world you don't exist
your body is comprised of photons which
is light
and light is information and information
is consciousness
correct so when you take it
let's walk through that breakdown again
of yours it's a very metaphysical one
it's important we might even
it's probably important enough to even
write down the breakdown again
yeah yeah okay so one more time we have
so in the quantum world you don't exist
your body is comprised of photons
okay so one is photons
yes okay okay
okay number one is photons okay um and
photons are light okay
which equals light yep okay and light
equals information okay
and information is consciousness
see that's what i love about you you
pick up on the important parts
you didn't let me breeze through that
one because this is very important
that's why in freemasonry you know it's
a search after
light it's a search after information
it's a search after consciousness
so this is by the way this is the
esoteric um
uh you know line of thought by the way
so you're not going to be seeing this in
any uh
you know school textbooks or anything
so um interesting but anyway so just
hear me out because that is a good
important part but it goes much deeper
and for those that are listening
only on audio one photons equal
light to light equals information
three information equals consciousness
and then it just it's very cyclical and
the cyclical so let's
let's uh let's explore this a little bit
so we have
a yeah 100
yeah which which is good i mean it's
it's it's really good with this at the
same time definitely
okay so we have um
we have a very we have a very
quantum mechanical unit of photon
we have that compromising
of light and we have light compromising
of information so when we
think of things like what chris lehen
calls the
info cognitive
universe that
that information is consciousness yes
so that we are consciousness
consciousness is exploring infinity as
our metaphysic
an unbounded map of phenomenological
experience
and so that consciousness being
informational is that we are eternally
exploring information and that we see
that
in this holographic
space-time reality that
is that appears to be quantum mechanical
it appears to have space time it appears
to have natural selection
but those are appearances which you as
you say will break down
everything is from within in a moment
everything's from within
so it's a very metaphysical idealist
perspective of like
all his mind like bernardo castro would
say that that is
your fundamental metaphysic is all is
mind
all is consciousness all is information
exploring infinity eternally
i love that and i would also like to
just say that for all of the people that
are physicalists
or that are trying to find a synthesis
between physicalism and consciousness
i would just say that this is not to say
physicalism
is not part of this equation it's to say
that
it is part of this equation
consciousness needs
these realities in order for it to
actually undergo the process of
exploring
the infinite possibility space space of
information
of phenomenal phenomenology that's why
people can have miraculous healing of
the body through the power of their own
mind
every time you think a negative thought
your body creates a stress hormone
that it's been physiologically proven to
mutate dna
yes so if thoughts can make us sick you
know yeah then it's very possible they
can make us well
now just let me um yeah because i know
we might be getting
kind of close on time one thing i was
going to say though is
so by looking at the curling photography
and
recognizing there really is this
energetic uh you know field
around us um so like i said in the in
the quantum world you do not exist
your body comprises of photons okay and
whenever you take a
photograph of your photonic
body okay this is why they say gypsies
never wants you to take photographs with
them because it captures their soul
essence etc
um but when you take a photograph in
broad daylight
okay of your body or your face which is
your bio energetic
photonic light signature think of it as
your own ip address right
what we're able to do is take that
photograph all the way from across the
world similar to remote
uh reiki healing you know as well that
you can do that which
raw is of the sun right ki
is ghee or chi or energy right
so it's the sun energy etc but scalar
energy when nikola tesla
understood and discovered scalar energy
he was quoted by saying
he knew that he found one of the rare
secrets of the universe because it's
non-electromagnetic in nature
where a radio wave etc is all
electromagnetic in nature so that means
the
scale yeah the farther that you
so the farther that you um go out from a
signal of a
uh you know radio signal it's going to
fade over time because it's
electromagnetic
scalar energy which i'm going to get to
in a second is non-electromagnetic in
nature so that means we can send this
energy
remotely pretty much to wherever you are
okay and that's the whole notion of what
we're uncovering with quantum
entanglement yes so this works through
quantum entanglement so that's why you
know like telephone telepathy
that's why you know your ears will
you'll start thinking of someone and the
next thing you know they're calling you
just like the paper uh you were thinking
man i'd really like to have that piece
of paper and i said hey would you like
to
you know same thing with the number and
everything it's it's all telepathy right
extra sensory perception is what it is
now let me just go through because i
know there'll be a million talking
points in between but let me just finish
the whole thing and then we'll we'll
recap especially scalar yeah yeah that's
what we're talking about
good good good okay so it's the same
type of energy that
you know emanated from uh warden cliff
and tesla's uh
towers we're actually connected to
desanca mandic you know through a friend
of ours
and um she's nicola tesla's
granddaughter and so anyway long story
short
we have this miniature miniaturized
tesla coil were you
the one that sent me
the data it may have been you i'm not
sure anymore may have been over a month
ago while i was finishing the synthesis
but
there was data around the
using light
and seeing light at that quantum
mechanical level and the way that it
affects
biology and specifically the way that
dna interacts well
with that that was not me but it backs
up what i'm about to say
i love this point so once again let me
finish the whole thing
okay before we talk about the other
point okay so yeah okay let me just
finish the whole thing it's never
finished speaks it speaks really deeply
to that reality
creation exactly okay so so anyway
and this is all verifiable with uh
polymerase chain reaction test which
we'll get to in a second
but what we're able to do is fire up the
miniature tesla coil okay combined with
the radionics machine
which is uh you know t galen hieronymus
which his wonderful work there
right and that ties in with bioresonance
therapy and biomagnetic therapy which
we'll cover in a little bit
and biodynamic craniosacral therapy
there's so many of them but
this is all round two stuff we have so
much to talk about
yeah we really do so anyway long story
short so that picture of your face
right because you're comprised of
photons and uh that's your ip address
and just how one cell phone can
communicate to another cell phone
wirelessly right just how a satellite
works or how a radio signal works except
it's non-electromagnetic in nature
we can send this energy to your
photograph i [ __ ] you not
and what you'll see and this it'd be one
thing like if we were just saying this
but we can actually verify this with pcr
tests we'll show you that in a second
and not the faulty you know coronavirus
pcr tests or whatever but what it does
is it emanates the scalar energy going
to your photograph which is your ip
address it can locate you anywhere you
are in the world i should not
and what it does is it whatever
vibration whatever pathogen virus or
bacteria is in the body
it literally does a reverse phase
harmonic so if the harmonic was
was four let's say it was vibrating at a
frequency of four say you had cancer or
whatever it was right
then what we do is we literally the
reverse phase harmonic would be two in
that case
right so whatever frequency is wrong
with your body
bacteria pathogen virus we invert the
frequency at a reverse phase harmonic
and send it to the photograph where it
affects your bioenergetic photonic light
signature known as
your aura or your morphogenetic field or
your
energy body as they call it okay because
everything is energy
and so what happens is it creates an
environment that it literally destroys
the molecular bonds of whatever virus
bacteria pathogen or whatever you have
wrong with you
so it creates an environment where it
cannot live and then you just you just
drink a bunch of water and what it does
is it takes those
you know viral proteins or whatever
essentially and it flushes
it out of your body the only thing when
you're doing this you have to
um you know drink a lot of water and
then what you do is
say you had like some incurable disease
or whatever it was that was
you know you go and get one of the most
advanced blood tests you can possibly
get a polymerase chain reaction test you
have to go to a special doctor to get
the real one
and you will see that that you are
completely
um it basically makes it an environment
where it cannot exist you know
beautiful who's currently doing the
bioresonance therapies that there's
places in la that are doing bio
resonance therapy
um but this is different scalar light
okay that's different it works in a
similar fashion but there's also
biomagnetic therapy
which uses the polarity of very strong
magnets to
to alkalize the body so there's
bioresonance therapy and there's
biomagnetic therapy
and then there's scalar light energy
which is also called
uh scalar energy it's also called prana
in the hindu and indian cultures it's
also called
zero point energy it's also called the
sun or star energy
okay okay same thing as like
energy just how remote distance reiki
healing works you know it's the same
similar type of thing
except just a little bit more high tech
and no it's not a miracle it's simply
science
would it be yeah it's really important
to target us
flags beyond the edge of what is known
and then work our way there as
these with these hypotheses and actually
do the
scientific method in the specific more
eccentric or
esoteric fields and push the edge super
duper
important it's extremely under in
funded right now yeah because there's a
lot of incentives in the way
of the existing perverse protocols
that are not about that they're about
the existing incumbent infrastructures
where there's profit motives
so we have to shatter the industrial
complex word pharmacy comes from the
greek word pharmakai
which means witchcraft and sorcery um
you know if you go look that up in a
greek dictionary or even look at it
online
and so you know there's unfortunately
there's no money to be made off healthy
humans
and so that's why this type of
technology including nicolas
definitely not definitely i definitely
don't agree with that there's a lot of
well here's there's a lot of their mind
there's a lot of money to be made money
is helping humans you should see the
amount
of wealthy people that really love and
even people
that are of my sort of much lower level
wealth that
love the idea of how can i get a
biometric
scan out of my existing states
of where i have slow pathology
developing and how can i tweak that
like a car what i meant to say yeah so
there's a lot of money to be made
what i'm saying is in their mind that up
to the cloud so all i'm saying is that
in their mind
there's more more money to be made off
the treatment rather than the cure
there you go that's that's the proper
way to say thank you for clarifying i
i agree with that so
there's obviously a lot that was right
there that we're gonna i think
table for round two which is gonna be
yeah crazy
interesting this has already been
ridiculously fascinating
yeah oh my goodness and like you said
like
man it is so damn important to get these
like to get these
main concepts into the into the sphere
of youtubes and the internet
be into more people's psyche because you
know that's
that's the crucial thing the one thing
that i keep repeating on this show
that i don't see other shows doing is
that
those ones that i listed earlier we need
more
the interviewer or another artist that's
a polymath or however we want to do this
but we need to live be capturing the
most profound
insights from the program and not only
the ones around
consciousness like we did here but we
have this these awesome ones around
seo that we did a little bit ago oh yeah
and they were really really really
insightful and and
oh my god yeah i mean they help break it
down yeah and
and people's businesses and simplicity
doesn't matter what you're achieving
seo can help you you know if you want
more exposure so we
we have to begin doing this on a more
consistent
basis and so i would just urge uh
the most popular podcast networks and
just flood them more and more with these
ideas of
cap capturing the salient points as we
as we undergo
dialectic non-hygiene by the way
dialectic
right yeah we'll get into that later in
pilot poly tricks
there's so much um okay let's do
the i think the last kind of like the
last thing here which is that
um i want you to unpack what you were
talking about when we first
sat down where you began kind of listing
off some of the things
we talked about this off the show as
well you have some thoughts around
i was sharing with you my kind of cyclic
consciousness exploring infinity
metaphysics and you were saying and the
idea is kind of like erwin laszlo
has talked about as well where you
undergo this torito
style of the big bang followed by a big
crunch style thing that
that is constantly cyclic but you scrape
the big bang i'm not buying it and then
you also scrape
uh darwinian natural selection and you
scrape
also around earth and so oh yeah
these are all things that are proven
these are all things that are proven by
spherical trigonometry i mean
just do the mathematics i mean i don't
want to get too
um in depth here because we all know
what happens to those that they do get
to in depth
um unfortunately they're not with us
very very long but um what i can say
what i'm at liberty to say is that nasa
comes from the
root word nasha which means to deceive
in hebrew it was started by a nazi
scientist by the name werner von braun
right there if that's not enough alone
to make sure that
you know that this is not a trustworthy
entity then i don't need to go any
further because if you can understand
based on the inception and what this is
about and what the symbols are
with nasa and what it's really really
about then
it i might as well save my breath you
know but let's just go ahead and
continue for entertainment purposes okay
so by the way um
i mean that alone pretty much says it
but yeah i mean
um the big bang theory okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep this very
um maybe elementary and maybe right
before we get to big bang theory just to
clarify on the
what then is occurring
if it's not i mean these are all inter
related concepts but then
what is occurring if not the
using the
jet fuels and propellants to oh yeah
rocket launchers are hoaxes i mean if
you look they go in distinctly a
parabolic curve i mean
there's not men in tiny ships going out
to outer space they're literally going
up out of view and then what's happening
is they're landing in controlled waters
is what's happening
um okay so then what is rocket launchers
what is my research what is occurring
thanks for that last bit what is
occurring again anti-dogmatic
always um what is occurring then when
we have like a celestial body like the
moon
okay which by the way the moon is
translucent in nature
so the moon is actually a translucent
object meaning that during certain
waxing during a blue moon right during
certain waxing and waning
cycles which by the way you only see the
same face of the moon you never see the
other side of it it's always
it does rotate but it's facing towards
you at all times it's like a frisbee and
you see the same side
it's simply rotating like this you never
see it the back side that's why pink
floyd wrote the
dark side of the moon which also has the
isaac newton which he was an early
freemason
isaac newton has the um you know the
prism with the um
the light reflecting or refracting out
of it
which is uh newton came up with this
theory of gravity okay theory of gravity
which is simply just that it's a theory
it's never been true so if if we're not
on a
spherical planet that's orbiting a light
source
oh yeah that is power i can give you an
experiment right now that will prove it
to you
and then you can do at home and then the
so this the sun
that's supposedly 93 million miles away
that's a yeah powering light on
the planet it's only a few thousand
miles away it's not 93 million see
that's the thing
what is nasa the sun is only a few
thousand it's not 93 million miles away
and how do you know that it's only a few
things well this is what i've researched
i mean no one knows anything but one
thing i can do is i can do a lot of
research and i can do what's called
discernment right
and so you know if an organization
called nasa
which it means to deceive is telling me
something how gullible would i be to
just buy it right off the bat right
so here's the thing so but what's in
there so
here's like what's the manipulation
what's the incentive because um
the thing is whether we understand their
incentive or not doesn't mean that
they're not
we don't we so the reason i remember you
said that scientists
like politicians scientists i remember
that part of course
yeah but are you asking why they're
doing this why they're paying this false
view of reality
upon the lower class let's do that
that's what they've always done
um just because we may not understand
why exactly which i have a good reason
of
one of the reasons why um because they
don't want us to have too much knowledge
they don't want you to become
too powerful they don't want you to um
recognize um
you know your own divinity from within
but but here's the thing
and why would that be why would that be
well
because then they can't have power over
us it's all about power it's all about
greed and control and power for these
individuals
okay so the idea is that there
is a there's a class they know
elite so here we go that have here we
got reverse
incentives to keep this will the
humanity in the dark that's why secret
societies exist they're not releasing
the knowledge
now let me put it this way and they make
you think that you evolve from monkeys
and that you're just on the stuck to the
side of a spinning ball
that's going nine 666 there they like
that number 666 million miles through
space
while orbiting the sun wall you know
with a thousand mile
per hour eastward rotation um which by
the way i'll get into an experiment here
in a second
but uh you know and people always used
to think that the earth was flat it was
only until you know
different types of uh freemasons came
along like newton and all these other
copernicus etc
right that were that were basically come
up with this whole round earth theory
okay now
it's complete [ __ ] and i'm going to
tell you exactly how and i'm going to
give you the mathematics behind it
i'm going to give you experiments that
have been done in the past and ones you
can do at home today
because i believe in proving everything
i say now you have to understand
i too was once brainwashed i too once
drank the kool-aid i too believed
everything i heard at school
i too believed everything i saw on the
science channel and and all this stuff i
too was gullible
i too was uh believable i too thought
that there was no harm that could ever
be done and the world was awesome
never experienced the double helical
structure
of dna yourself but you believe in it
because it's been proven
by rosalind franklin by watson and crick
watson which were the two nobel prize
award-winning scientists that discover
the shape of the double helix of our dna
while high on lsd d-lyseric acid
diethylamide which has a tryptamine
nucleus
which tryptamine is two trivial
enzymatic steps from tryptophan
and the thing is is it's an accelerated
dose of dimethyltryptamine which
ayahuasca the banisterius cappy vine the
ayahuasca vine
ironically grows in the same shape of
the double helix dna
which um yeah and so but the thing is
though is you believe
this and which is very interesting it's
do i believe it um i believe it's a
possibility
um i believe that everything is a
possibility fair
fair okay so i don't really believe
necessarily anything what i do believe
is that everything is
well we have to have some sort of
communal sense making
which assists in the most optimal
trajectory of sanitary flourishing
and there's discernment there's a
research and discernment that occurs in
this process
it's a lot though to because i just want
to also be fair joshua for myself and
for so many people
just that like we have to be a little i
think potentially
maybe more gentle because it's it's
quite
hard to say like i too was once
completely brainwashed you know what i
mean
well i don't mean that in a negative way
i just meant that i was drinking the
kool-aid
because it's also your institution it's
also not binary in the sense that
people that are understanding which is
what i tried to prove with that double
helical structure of dna because
you it's hard you can't just say that
there's one side which is completely
binary brainwashed that
thinks all of the science believes the
television tells them and then there's
the other side which is one hundred
percent completely binary right yeah
there's mixes and i'm not saying there's
nothing mixing just telling you
information
yeah i'm not telling you that i'm right
i'm just telling you information that
i've researched and then you're like
you're doing
the sun being a couple thousand miles
away i originally thought
the same thing everyone did that the
earth was around um until
and then i heard about the flat earth
theory here's the runway go ahead i
thought it takes the right
yeah just because if not we'll never get
there take the runway um so i became a
flat earther
by trying to disprove the flat earth i
too i okay i was using you know heavy
language there right because people
don't like to be called out on
their [ __ ] as an old saying right um
but the whole thing is is that i too
believed um everything i heard pretty
much from the scientific communities
right
the earth is round and so when i heard
about the flat earth theory i thought it
was so ridiculous i was like man this
stuff is
ridiculous why would everyone why would
anyone ever think that
right and it's just something that we're
taught
at a very young age at the time we're
children we say
you know we're showed this round earth
okay it's called blank slate theory you
know you can obviously
manipulate it so we're shown this big
round earth
and uh they say that the earth is round
and we say well if the earth is round
then
you know as a child we would tell the
teacher you know what about the people
at the bottom why won't they fall off
and they say
oh oh that's gravity that's gravity no
need to look any further and so we just
we bought into it at a very young age
and we've grown up and we've been
conditioned
through the backgrounds on our computers
and through the symbols and all the
corporate logos that hey we're living on
this
you know round earth due to gravity
gravity is the only thing that's keeping
this ship afloat
okay now here's the thing sir isaac
newton whenever he saw the he discovered
the theory of gravity which has been
it's just a theory it's never been
proven
due to density objects fall to earth if
i have a brick in one hand and a feather
in the other
and i let go both of them at the same
time okay which one do you think is
going to hit the ground
first obviously the brick right because
it weighs more
okay but it's not due to gravity it's
due to density so that so the
idea is is that any time something is
more dense than the air like the apple
that isaac newton
you know observed that fell to the
ground anytime something is more dense
than the air
it will fall to earth not due to gravity
due to
density which is mass times cubic volume
times weight
and so the whole thing is is that um
that yeah we just buy this complete lie
okay now now
give me a second to re um to re invoke
my thoughts for a second okay because
there's a lot to cover you're gonna be
hearing a lot here so the whole thing is
um
yeah so so there's actually never been a
scientific experiment not
one that is shown a heliocentric object
that shows water gravitized around it
it's just not the natural tendencies of
water
water always finds its level if you
notice the natural occurrences of water
it always finds its level that's why
there's a thing called the level that
you use to measure how level something
is and guess what's in the middle of it
water okay so it's like they're just
throwing in your face they're
hysterically laughing
at you guys you know they're
hysterically laughing like deep
belly diaphragm like laughing like real
laughing
at people that believe this um because
it's part of their their magic you know
it's part of their
um a thing you know it's like they're
rubbing our faces in it they're mocking
it you know
mocking us with it so here's the thing
so
um so there's no scientific experiment
that shows any heliocentric object that
has water gravitizing around it it's not
anything naturally occurring in nature
okay and then the other thing too is
that if gravity is such a strong
force to hold the eiffel tower stuck if
you can answer me this one question then
maybe i'll change my mind but until
someone gives me a legit answer
i'm of this opinion how is gravity
such a strong force to hold the eiffel
tower stuck to the side of a spinning
ball
but yet it's weak enough to allow birds
and insects to fly so freely
if someone can answer give me an honest
answer that question i would love to
hear
now continuing beyond that uh look up a
guy named samuel robottom
which basically if you were born on the
middle of an island somewhere basically
and nobody told you that the earth was
round what would your eyes naturally
observe and see
you wouldn't think that it was round
would you in fact when you go up in an
airplane
i mean there's just so much this is like
this might even be some round two stuff
because there's so many experiments and
everything totally like that's why like
if the earth was round
so put your hands like this for me real
quick okay so just like this
okay so if the earth was round okay then
that means if you fly in an
airplane that means keep your hands just
like that okay so that means if you fly
in an airplane
that means that the the um pilot would
have to dip the nose down
do an actual ball you're not doing a
ball like an actual yeah just like this
just a ball okay so that means that if
you're flying in an airplane the pilot
would have to dip the nose down
every five to 15 minutes or so to stay
with the curvature of the earth
but that's not what happens when you
find an airplane you go straight up
you go straight across and look if
you're going straight across and the
earth is round
well then where the hell are you going
out here in outer space or something
right
now a lot of people would say so that's
another thing okay um
the other thing is that they claim nasa
to deceive
claims that there's a thousand mile
eastward rotation
okay a thousand mile per hour eastward
rotation if that's the case that means
that planes would have to take off
and land on runways that are moving that
means they'd have to head
west in order to fly north but that's
not what happens when you observe this
okay
the other thing is um like there's been
experiments where
and you can do this yourself okay you'll
stand on the edge of a beach okay so
remember the earth is 25 000 miles in
circumference okay
25 000. that's the official uh
numerology there okay
so if you stand there's been experiments
people do this on
on youtube they've even recorded it and
uploaded it but
if you stand on the edge of a beach and
watch a ship sail
out from the the shore off until the
horizon right
if you stay trained on that if you keep
your eye trained on that ship as it
slowly steals it's going to get smaller
and smaller until eventually it
disappears
now most people think oh that's because
it's going over the curvature of the
earth
well that's not the case because if we
take a pair of binoculars
then the ship comes back okay and then
once we're tuned into the ship on the
block binoculars and we're watching the
ship sail out to sea
okay finally we're watching on the
micros or the binoculars
okay and then finally once it seals out
far enough
okay then the ship disappears again so
then surely people would say oh it's got
to go over the curvature of the earth
now i mean it's so far
right but if you take a telescope
and you look at the ship again it the
ship comes back
now you're tuned in on this telescope
and you're watching you're still trained
on the ship that's still going
flat straight out across the earth okay
and then finally when the the ship gets
so small you can barely see it with the
telescope
it disappears so then surely all the
skeptics are going to say wow
that's surely got to uh uh be the
curvature of the earth then
right keep in mind 25 000 miles in
circumference circumference okay not
radius
so you have to keep in there the
mathematics when you're doing this i'll
go over the spherical trigonometry in a
second
which will really get you going but what
happens is
once that ship disappears in the
telescope okay it goes over the
curvature of the earth right like as so
to deceive would like you to know nasa
and asha
started by a nazi scientist warner von
braun which has
on his gravestone a reference to the
firmament over the earth
because apparently even in the bible
they said god separated the waters from
above and the waters from below and made
a space in the middle
and talks about the firmament so warner
von braun look at his gravestone has a
quote on the firmament
but you have that telescope and the ship
disappears surely it's got to be over
the edge now
right or over the the curvature of the
earth but if you take it even
and you can do this experiment yourself
you take an even higher powered
telescope
and you put it back on and the ship
still comes
back i [ __ ] you not so that proves
that the earth is not round now i'm not
saying it's completely flat
okay i'm just telling you that it's even
nasa and neil degrasse tyson even nasus
came out and said
oh by the way the earth is actually
pear-shaped
you can look this up they nasa came out
neil degrasse tyson which is another
freemason came out and said
that the earth is pear-shaped just type
in uh neil
degrasse tyson pear-shaped you can pull
up the video on youtube there's a little
clip of him saying it
um let's see they're also highest order
shape deviations with me
okay so so basically one second let's
let me
let me just adjust this to actually get
the the search on yeah and just
realizing for all of you listening
all of you listening just realized it's
gonna take more
uh than a five minute explanation of
this to break an entire lifetime of
programming
so just be aware um but that's why i'm
gonna give you some experiments you can
do
uh for yourself this is from the search
of
this earth is pear-shaped just typing
and the answer here from nasa is there
are also
other higher order shape deviations
which make the earth slightly pear
shaped with the larger southern
hemisphere surface this area so that's
just trying to then in the northern
hemisphere
but at a level of a kilometer or so
in radial girth exactly so that's
that's not that's very minimal and
yeah well here's the thing regardless of
how many well first of all you're
reading from nasa which is nasha
right um but also we're talking about
neil degrasse tyson one of the most
you know foremost scientists out there
right that he
look up the clip on youtube you know
don't go to the people that are going to
say they're going to deceive you go to
the deceivers themselves
neil degrasse tyson said the earth is
pear-shaped okay so look more into it
but my question is if the earth is
pear-shaped then what are these
perfectly round
spherical images that we're seeing
um in our science books so nasa can't
even get their own story straight
well here it says that it's a level of a
kilometer i don't care
what they say because it's um i just
don't trust them you know they they
have no reason to be trusted now here's
the other thing there's other points on
the runway
that you want to keep hitting yes
exactly okay okay so check this out
speaking of runway if we were really on
it like i said earlier a thousand mile
per hour eastward rotation that means
planes would have to take off and land
on runways that were moving just
riddle me that i have a log of a couple
of the things that i want to get back to
yeah yeah for sure so so the other thing
too is so so they say nasa says that
we're
you know we're going 666 million miles
through space they really like that
number 666.
so we're going 666 miles through
666 million miles through space with a 1
000 mile per hour eastward rotation
okay wall orbiting the sun so i want you
to imagine that in your head okay
going traveling through space okay 666
million miles
a thousand miles per hour eastward
rotation
while orbiting the sun okay now
here's an experiment you can do at home
so you can prove this to yourself
you take a long exposure camera and you
sit it on the ground and you point it up
towards the north star
and you let it sit for three days
there's also people on youtube doing
this
as well there's even people that have
their own little miniature rock as they
send up and then it hits the firmament
and then it
you know kind of uh dissipates but so
the whole thing is yeah the firmament as
mentioned in the bible like
not that that's you know the best sense
of reference but it does have some
truths
so here's the thing if you take a long
exposure camera and point it towards the
north star
and just record the the movement of the
heavens for three days
okay and then you do a time lapse and
you play it back you will see
okay prove this to yourself this is no
he said she said nasa said i don't give
a [ __ ] about any of that i care about
real experiments okay like i told you
with the telescope and everything else
now the thing is is um when you look and
play the video back
you'll see that the north star stays the
same and literally all the heavens
revolve around us so it's not the sun
that is at the center of the galaxy
and all the planets revolving around the
solar system or yeah essentially yeah
exactly
because we're covering a lot of material
but what i'm saying is
is that do this experiment yourself okay
you'll see
that everything that the earth stays
stationary and that we are the center
of this solar system at least and that
the heavens are rotating around
us i [ __ ] you not look this stuff up now
with all that being said the elite class
a lot of people ask okay so why would
they be doing this okay
like that's great and all josh like i
did i've even had people that said i did
the long exposure camera
i did the whole ship sailing off of c
you know i did all this like they're
like okay so obviously you know you've
proven it to me
um but they say but i just don't get why
they're trying to do this
and i always say just because you don't
understand why
doesn't mean that they're not doing it
and here's the thing too
is that um you know the elite class or i
don't even like calling them elite the
predatory class
has always tried to depict a false view
of reality upon the lower class
since the beginning of time and the
reason why i think one of the reasons
why they're doing it
is because they know that if they
convince you that there was this big
bang
which is basically saying that there was
nothing and then nothing exploded
and then that created something you know
if you can believe that you can believe
anything
so i'm not buying it but the whole thing
is the big bang theory the theory of
evolution
right and the round earth they're all
tied in together from my research
they're all tied in together to sell you
the idea that you evolve from apes
you're just one tiny little speck in
this galaxy that's on that's a part of
another galaxy that's even bigger than
another galaxy in another big
of this vast vast universe okay and um
they make you think that that basically
since you evolved from apes and you're
stuck on the side of a spinning ball
that doesn't really matter because that
spinning ball is
you know one fraction of the size of all
the the vastness of the
universe they make you think that your
life doesn't matter and if they make you
think that your life doesn't matter
then they know that you're not going to
try to um become enlightened
yes exactly now here's the thing now
last thing i want to say on this
okay and then i really am going to have
to go because the time and everything
but um
the whole thing is um if you go to
nasa.gov their website themselves
and you download their images like the
one where the guy's standing on the moon
and looking at the earth right you know
that famous image
go to nasa.gov download the image from
their own stuff themselves it's proven
to be cgi
i promise you that i had a guy that
helped that worked at jpl
but anyway so you download the images
from
nasa.gov you upload it to adobe
photoshop
and then you drop the saturations and
the levels down and you'll be able to
see a black box
that it was pretty much like clip art
copy and pasted around the earth
this is another experiment you can do
yourself so if the earth really is round
then why are they trying to
um you know hide this stuff from us why
are they trying to
manipulate this and use cgi and all this
you know that's my question
and so when you tie that in with the
theory of gravity and
and the round earth and then darwinism
evolution and then the big bang
it's all to sell you the idea that you
don't matter and that this life doesn't
matter and just keep working and go to
sleep and
watch tv and that's it you know so
that's basically all i have to say about
that
i mean there might be little tidbits of
here that you may you know have a
counter argument this or that but at the
end of the day do the experiments i told
you about research those experiments
um and then then come talk to me after
that because right now we're just going
based off information that
you know preconceived ideas
and just realize last thing is it's
gonna take more than five minutes of me
explaining this
to break an entire lifetime of
programming so just be aware of that
and and maybe you'll end up like i did
where you didn't believe the flat earth
theory
and you go out and you try to disprove
it and then that's what ends up making
you a believer
the unique thing about me and the unique
thing about this
about this program is that
we don't play the game
of
taking that unique
artistic expression of consciousness
that arises
and this and destroying it straw manning
it all that type of stuff we let it
flower
and then myself and the audience
get to decide on
your memetic spread
and whether the ideas are
resonant yes and so then we can leave it
there
for now yeah and i have many yes
pieces in that on round two 100 to hit
back on
that may be insightful
for the further elevation of dialogue
and exploration yet and the other thing
too is
is that um
yeah yeah 100 what was i there was one
last thing i was going to say
about that in particular oh yeah so
just like the whole making money thing
people come to me they say i want to
learn how to make money i say okay how
many hours a day
do you spend learning how to make money
the answer is always no
nothing you know or very little and then
i say well don't be surprised
when you look in your bank account
there's not much money there right
so when any time someone tries to debate
me you know a healthy debate you know
obviously right we're all friends we're
all
you know regardless we're not going to
let views separate us but anytime
someone tries to debate me on
anything especially the flat earth this
is my question
how many hours of research have you done
on this very specific topic that
renders you a great credit to your name
to be able to speak on such topics
because i know for me
i've spent hours and hours and hours and
days and weeks i've
become so enthralled and interested in
this i've read all the literature i've
looked at all the videos
i've put in the 10 000 hours on this
topic
my question to anyone that would like to
debate me on this topic is how many
hours have you put in
and if the answer is very slim then what
makes you an expert to speak on this
topic
that's the last thing i've got to say
mic drop
generally speaking there's
an important resonant frequency to what
you just said
which is that there's a
within people's north star explorations
there's an amount of investment that
people
take with their consciousness and their
energy to
look at the fitness landscape of ideas
and try to parse for signal
across discipline synthesize come up
with
insightful revelations about the nature
of consciousness and reality
and i appreciate what you shared
and that i think round two and feel that
round two
we can get some interesting tennis
going on on that exactly i always say
you know don't tell me what you believe
don't tell me what you've been told from
a very young age especially from major
institutions
show me how long you've been researching
this subject and tell me what you've
researched
and then we can have an intelligent
discussion otherwise it's all based on
preconceived notions of what we've been
told i think it's super
interesting that although everything
you just did the runway on
was your expression of consciousness and
and rich and and aromatic
yeah i just want to say that it's really
interesting how even though
that happened that fundamentally
metaphysically we're aligned as
consciousness being fundamental and
eternally exploring
it's just the thing is there's something
really interesting about well the thing
is and i'm just speaking up about this
because i just don't want humanity to go
further down the slippery slope
and so the whole thing is like the
reason why they don't want this
information out there
is because the round earth theory is the
mother
of all the great conspiracy theories
this is the one
theory that once this one theory gets
out
to the entire world which is really not
a theory if anything gravity is a theory
i mean
but anyway this is the one conspiracy
theory the flat earth right
this is the great mother lode of all
conspiracies because this is the one
thing that once the average human wakes
up to this idea and they
do the research okay they don't just
believe what they heard in kindergarten
and believed it and then never looked
back right they actually take a critical
eye and do what i've done which is
actually take time
everyone's quick i would also like to
put that the one
usually people insert here is is fiat
currency
yeah yeah that's the creature of jekyll
island yeah so when you're fractional
reserve banking
i know you listen and so when you put
when you put it in the hierarchy
well you say
once people wake up to this it's gonna
take everything down because then people
are finally gonna realize that they've
been lied to
you know mark twain another freemason he
said that it's a lot easier to convince
people
or no it's a lot easier the lie spreads
around the world faster than the truth
puts his shoes on
yes but he also said that it's easier to
fool someone
than it is to convince them that they've
been fooled and right now that's what
i'm trying to tell you guys is that
i'm trying to convince you that you've
been fooled do the research and prove me
wrong i know
i love it round two super pumped that's
gonna be
i love that all right and i guess the
last thing
last question is because we've already
done so much around
consciousness and nature of reality we
can unpack that more in round two
it's a very fun silly question yeah it
actually
has a little bit of metaphysical
implications right it is what is your
favorite food my favorite food
has got to be i would say lobster man i
just really love
lobster you know why
because the way that it tastes i just
love seafood you know
um actually it doesn't even really have
to be lobster i just love
like like genre of food or like
individual dish
i guess both so i so what i like is i
like italian food greek food
what what in italian what in greek
what's special like
you know i hate to say it because it's a
code word for some other [ __ ] but i do
like pasta
um you know um pizza is okay i guess but
um really just intricate dishes like
that greek is um
like gyros are good i don't eat much
meat i'm mostly vegan
um chinese food is really good like
shrimp fried rice and all that stuff
um i like thai food thai food's got to
be probably one of my favorite foods in
the world
and pad thai and pad sioux and then um
let's see what else um
and then uh seafood you want to do yeah
yeah seafood's really really good too
so i love that stuff that was the first
time on the show that
a guest went into the different cultural
genres of food
and broke those down by their favorites
yeah i like that you did that
a lot um that's great and the the
metaphysical
implications of the question are
something i only realized
like a week ago asking this question on
the show
which is that it's funny because the
same way that
individual conscious agents have
preferences for tastes of food
you can think about that on that's a
micro phenomena and on a macro phenomena
consciousness has different
phenomenological experiential
playgrounds
that it enters into to have those
experiences
as tastes and i love indian food too
anything that's like
i love it i love it i love it i love it
okay so all right josh that's
that's that's a wrap oh my gosh all
right well i guess
um i guess as a as a brief
uh recap uh we covered a ridiculous
amount of epicness
we have just in general piercing the
veil of reality
we have that giving the world's best
ideas maximum exposure by reverse
engineering seo
algorithms and that's doing things like
actually exploring the google patents
reverse engineering those reverse
engineering the competitors
and what they do you can use tools like
semrush to do so
again this deeper keyword analysis
and then you create unique landing pages
for each
keyword and that will drive your north
star goals and you can use i need
articles.com to do so
again seo is the beautiful funnel
that gets you all of your leads your
sales people using your product and
services you can funnel them into any of
these
other places afterward as well
and that also beyond seo going into
things like photons equals light
light equals information information
equals consciousness
and the entire exploration of
all of the pieces of content around
those those fields so again you can
check out the link
in the bio below is joshua erp's
instagram profile
you can check him out he has very
thought-provoking stories he posts there
he's got a lot of other really
awesome content that he links to there
for you to go check out around
seo that graphic that we were exploring
is on his website which is linked in the
instagram as well
and that also
thank you very much for tuning in
massively appreciate you
super duper grateful and joshua
thank you for coming on the phone this
has been
awesome what an incredible round one
the thing is when i opened up for edward
snowden at secret knock
a few years ago which is also on my
instagram videos or pictures
edward snowden came out and he said
something incredibly profound
he said the reason why most people don't
speak up about the truth
right no matter how obscure it is like
you know flat earth or this or that
vaccines 5g whatever
the reason why is because of their fear
of criticism
okay and that's something that really
resonated with me it's interesting and
so the thing is is um
you know the only way to avoid criticism
is to do nothing
say nothing and be nothing that's right
and so that's why
even though that you know i might be
highly criticized you know go ahead
criticize me all you want i'm i'm here
to give me the truth and i'm here to um
whether you like it or not whether it
bro breaks your programming or not i'm
here to say
and we're doing it in different ways the
thing is like the thing is i always
speak my truth and
doesn't resonate with everyone because
sometimes you know you can't teach a
baby how to walk when they're in the
crawling stage you know
and so we have to progressively you
can't pull flowers to make them grow
yeah you can't think you can't teach a
baby how to walk within a crawling stage
so
so you have to slowly and kindly guide
them towards the right direction
you know and by the way just on the flat
earth thing look up some youtube videos
dave murphy
type in dave murphy flat earth and type
in eric dubay flat earth those are two
great resources um and videos and you
know
that have done thesis on this and and um
it's highly enlightening to say the
least
and i do i didn't believe it at first
either the way that i would also
illustrate it visually like we do on on
high level perceptions chapter four
portals is that
it's really important as people endeavor
away from the consensus reality
game a neuroticism of the evolutionary
pacer that's actually
unsustainable and you see these like
game b
omni-win civilizational architects that
are
happening we have to
be more excited
about supporting people that are trying
to do their best to go
into these territories of these genius
level mutations although some of them
might be
wrong and some of them might be deeply
right and that it's extremely
important to identify that and that's
why we say at the end of every episode
do let us know your thoughts in the
comments below do your own research
and if the video resonated like it share
it with other people subscribe to the
channel
also that support the other scientists
spiritual leaders entrepreneurs
engineers artists people in their fields
that
are in your communities and around the
world that you believe and support them
and execute your own north stars into
the world and leverage these patterns
that josh was sharing on the show around
seo
and we can build that more beautiful
future our hearts know as possible
and that's that's a wrap that's a wrap
folks love you very much thanks for
tuning in
we'll see you soon peace
that's it my man that's it